The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan Dutton that,
why do I say like,
why do I say it like that?
A flashlight.
Flashlight.
Look,
I'm trying to get excited about it.
Uh,
it's brought to you about a rubber thing that you fucked.
That feels better than your hand.
Yeah.
They call it the fleshlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net and are in the code named Rogan and you can save 15% off the
number one sex toys for men.
Treat yourself to,
you know,
you masturbate ally,
you enjoy yourself.
You know,
you should spend your money on your bed and you should spend your money on your
masturbation instead of like,
you could go out to tea,
did get some beers and pay for the same price that you would for our flashlight
and you'd get so much more enjoyment out of like just having eight beers and a
shot at Applebee's,
you know?
Okay.
You lost me there somewhere.
Some way lost me.
I was with you.
I was trying to,
I was rooting on Ya.
I was hoping you going to pull it out.
Can I of an Applebee's flashlight asshole.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
They had all,
they have the asphalt paving a mile,
two days in a row,
two asshole questions in a row.
I think that's why I just,
I don't know.
Good question,
Mandy.
Ever since I've been doing the podcast where you guys,
when I first got here,
they just had one size fits all.
Now you know they've expanded the flashlight,
so I want to know how long once they've expanded.
Yeah,
they've gotten miles vampire miles.
They've got all kinds of freak shit.
I should have been a vampire sucking dick like a savage.
The erotic ness of erotic next.
Is that a word?
Just get some brain field rotation.
The teeth sliced by your Dick with blood coming out of her fangs.
Gary's,
Ooh.
Sucking your helmet.
Tremendous.
Would she be able to do it and not hurt you?
Yeah,
those vampires could do it all.
Fucked professional.
That's why they lived in a 2000 though.
Fucking worthless after fucking 80 yee.
Ah,
go to Joe rogan.net.
Entering the code named Rogan.
Save yourself some money.
Dirty bitches were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t.
Makers of Alpha brain.
Get up on it.
Yeah,
it,
uh,
what Alpha brain is is a dude.
You should be ours.
We got to buy it today.
He's crazy.
This,
um,
go to [inaudible] dot com and explore all the different products.
Alpha brain is the nootropic.
It's a,
uh,
essentially what nootropics are as vitamins and minerals that have been shown to
enhance cognitive function.
There's some,
uh,
some debate about all this stuff and there's some controversy behind it.
So go and Google it.
I personally believe in that had been,
I'd been taking nootropics,
nootropics rather before,
uh,
I had ever taken Alpha brain and Alpha brain is without a doubt that all the
stuff I've tried,
my favorite,
but there's a lot of other good stuff out there to build.
Roman [inaudible],
that guy,
he has one.
We talked about this,
Joey called neuro one,
and I believe he came up with his,
because he had suffered a bunch of concussions,
right.
And he was trying to get himself some nutrients that it would help his brain
function.
So that was him.
Um,
in Roman law scans a really good
one,
that neuro one,
but Alpha brain is the one we sell.
If you're interested in it and you order it and you the first 30 pills,
there's a 100% money back guarantee.
If you try it and you're like,
this doesn't,
I don't feel anything.
Fuck this.
This is stupid.
You get your money back.
I,
that's how much we believe in it as much.
How much people who use it enjoy it and order it again.
And because we don't want to rip anybody off.
I don't want anybody feeling like somehow or another they got fucked.
So it's real simple.
30 days or 30 pills rather,
the first 30 pills,
you don't even have to return them.
You just say this stuff,
socks,
you get your money back.
It's that simple.
Um,
we have a shroom tech sport,
which is,
uh,
an athletic supplement.
A and endurance supplements got a lot of B 12 in it and cordyceps mushrooms.
And it's uh,
based on the idea that there's certain mushrooms that actually can aid in your,
your body's ability to process oxygen.
Like people in high altitudes would eat these mushrooms to help them give them
energy to at high altitudes and um,
controversy behind that too.
I like it.
It's great stuff.
There's a lot of B 12 and eight which is also excellent for you.
And then the shroom tech immune and then a new moon,
which would say five HTP and l tryptophan supplement,
which can enhance your serotonin levels.
All interesting stuff.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and just check it out.
How many levels of trip,
how much strip the fan is that like if I have a problem sleeping,
if I take check trip to fan,
I'm pass out for a few weeks.
No,
no,
no.
For the first few weeks when people said you take trip to fan,
you know when you're a high strung,
you take it home at night for the first week,
eight days it works.
Then you outgrow it.
Like anything else.
If I take that with a trip to find the daytime.
Well,
I feel tired.
Have you taken it a day?
I only take it at night.
Okay.
That's,
yeah.
I take it before I go to sleep.
I'm not trying to be cute,
you know?
No,
no,
no.
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
You say you're gonna take Melatonin if you can't go to sleep.
Do you ever taken I used to.
I used to.
Well,
Tom is nice,
but it lasts eight days.
You,
I'll do it.
You got to start a new cycle every like 10 days or it right.
You have to eat too many of them,
but it does work.
What's the Turkey Turkey's trip to fan trip to.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I just,
I think right now it was,
yeah.
Yeah.
Turkey.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com blah,
blah,
blah.
Enter in the code named Rogan.
Save yourself 10% any and all orders.
All right.
Dirty freaks.
The funniest human on earth is here.
Mad Flavor,
Aka Joe Diaz.
Let's get the party started.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Bam.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the one and only the king of swing.
Remember when,
uh,
Mitzi was calling you fat baby for awhile.
A long time.
I loved it.
And I would walk past her and she'd blow my stomach out or they have fingers.
You make believer was a needle.
Do you remember that?
In her world?
I would walk
by and she'd stopped me,
all fat baby and she poked me like she had a needle in her hand and by yourself
she'd go.
So like if the air was coming out of my stomach in her own head and she would
giggle to herself that she did that for the rest of my life.
Baby,
she had a 40th anniversary on Saturday.
Uh,
the club,
which a part of me got sentimental Yami autonomy jerked off on my pillow,
you know what I'm saying?
But like the comedy store always be a part of our lives.
It's like Vietnam for some people.
They went,
they'll never go back.
It's that.
It's good.
We'll just leave it there and our memory.
But yeah,
it's installations.
It was a huge part of our lives.
No doubt about that place was,
uh,
there was,
a real workshop.
But you know what,
I'm still recovering from Atlanta.
I just got rested yesterday from Atlanta pitchers especially fry and I thank you
very much.
If you came out to the shows,
the support Joe Rogan and this taping,
it was fucking brilliant.
I mean,
when we had Duncan stuck,
I had a serious,
you know,
I don't do that shit.
I didn't go on stage and try to be cute.
I just stuck my head out to see what was out there.
I had never been in this seat before.
You know,
before you bungee jump,
you talk a lot of shit before you do anything in life.
You talked a lot of shit.
Then you're there and you look in.
That's what it felt like to me guys.
It was like going,
yeah,
I'll jump off that diving board.
And you run up to the top and when you get up there,
you look over and you're like,
Ooh.
That was a little bit more when I looked into that tabernacle fucking theater
and it just wasn't one level.
It was two levels.
Then that third fucking level guys,
and they started cheering and you ran in with Jeff and you're like,
what happened?
Did you go on stage?
I didn't go on stage.
Me and Duncan just popped her fucking heads out there.
At that point I knew it was all fucking up pill because the energy was alive,
but we didn't have to do nothing.
We didn't say a word,
no cock sucker,
no being cute.
We just went like that to look just to see if everybody was seated.
So if you came out to the Tabernacle,
you rocked my motherfucking world last week.
First year I was nervous as fuck.
And uh,
you know,
I love it man.
I love getting nervous though.
Like a little kid.
That's what it's all about.
So I had a great time in Atlanta.
Downtown was great.
Thank you very much for taking his Joe.
Thanks for coming.
What a great fucking,
you know,
I've always been in the suburbs.
Whenever we do the punchline,
the laughing whenever you always out in the fucking suburbs.
I was the first time I was in the heart of Atlanta,
chocolate city.
They had hot black chicks,
hot white chicks.
I sat down one morning fucking make a believer.
I was smoking fucking weed and I'm just watching these women walk by me.
Oh my God.
They were hot in the morning going to work and shit.
It was fucking amazing guys.
They're really was.
Who was the limo driver?
How far you're right though.
I'm fine.
[inaudible] after I tackled the and Shit,
I'm just listening to you.
That was funny that you said concussions because for somebody who's got a lot of
concussions,
you don't act like it because I think the crazy has overcome the concussion.
Who for me?
No,
for real.
[inaudible] like some people you see them after they got 20 concussions and
their little fucking robots,
but this guy,
how many concussions do you think you've had?
I heard stories at that motherfucker.
You you've had me.
Yeah.
I had walked to two to nothing from violence,
football and a motorcycle accident.
What does the housing,
both pretty violent.
No,
I,
you know,
you just talk bro.
Sometimes you just tackle somebody,
you think you're doing your job and all sudden you walk away and you're like,
Ooh,
I know,
but listen to what you just said.
Nothing from football or motorcycle racing to super violent things.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I put you man.
Didn't want people to think I got hit and everybody records held by a person.
One time I was on an Xr one 25 and I was racing by the swaps where they built
the Meadowlands and I turned my head and there was a pipe sticking.
I might just,
I didn't want to believe I didn't even bleed.
I just,
it just want to hit the floor so it wasn't as bad as Jesus.
Listen Bro.
Those concussions,
those,
when he shot me,
the,
the limo driver,
remembering the limo driver.
When you were talking about weed or something like that and you were just like,
smelled this nug yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
You videoed that.
Oh,
we had such a good time with him when I was telling you we can't put that out
there because they want to get him in trouble.
If the audio we can play right now,
if you're black,
you just stopped going to Africa.
I remember we went off on that shit in the car.
Just go to St Louis.
Yeah.
I mean this is the truth.
You black stop going to fucking Africa.
You can just kind to get scared.
It gets too real.
Go to St Louis where they keep it.
Moderate brothers or people at Mater.
That's the woods.
Richard Pryor from Peoria,
Illinois.
Those areas there.
That's where a Malcolm x and all those brothers are from.
That's the heartbeat of Africa right there.
Just keep it to that right there.
I think Red Fox grew up with Malcolm X,
one of those guys.
Really?
It was either Red Fox or a or a rich,
I think it was Red Fox.
I'm sorry.
Red Fox at Malcolm x grew up together.
What about the dude in New York that caused all the problems?
He was somebody who's tour manager or something,
wasn't he James Brown's 12 manager.
What's the black guy that always gets involved when somebody black gets in
trouble?
He just lost a lot of ways.
These controversial I'll show up to.
Yeah.
James Brown's tour.
Somebody.
Yeah,
look at his resume.
Somewhere along the line he was involved with something.
That's how he got his claim to fame at first.
Somebody House Sharpton get his claim to see and look and see.
I may be wrong,
I could be wrong,
but I'll Sharpton did something with James Brown or somebody
that you need your own Google search engines.
You can just type in like like something sharp.
Damn.
Fuck sorry guys.
I'm just going to look.
James Brown up here.
Yeah,
they'll put it out.
Sharpton.
So you see what it says?
He became a tour manager for James Brown in 1973 wow.
Wow.
How fuck you never know.
I never do that to get up.
Hey,
he's hustling man.
He's out there hustling.
Look a lot of people shit on Al Sharpton as far as I can tell al Sharpton and
hurting anybody.
And guess what,
even though maybe sometimes he's imbalanced with,
uh,
his,
his racialism,
you know,
the way he goes after the racial angle and every sort of story,
even though he's imbalanced,
I think we probably need a little bit of imbalance to check some of the white
people in America.
That's a fact.
I really think that knowing that a Jesse Jackson or an al out is out there,
these bulldogs of,
of anti black racism.
I mean,
I think the unnecessary,
I don't,
you know,
I don't think Jesse Jackson is the same.
I don't think Al Sharpton's the Saint,
but I think they're playing necessary role.
I know that sounds ridiculous,
but how are they any more ridiculous than Newt Gingrich or this Guy John Davids
that was running for president?
What's his name?
Davis.
I don't know.
The white guy.
We talked about him yesterday.
God Damn it.
What the fuck is his name?
Is that his name?
Tony Man.
Just go to CNN.
No,
just,
you know,
the problem is
seriously,
there's only so much room on the Goddamn hard drive and there's more information
coming in every day.
What the fuck is the dude's name?
He's in the news right now.
We need to upgrade our brains.
We need to be able to do that.
They need to figure that out where we can start putting more dead people's
brains in our bodies or something.
Dead peoples like swapping out or just adding to it.
You know,
it's really hard to get your body to absorb other people's stuff like organs and
like they've had hand transplants and most of them fail,
but it doesn't give me rejects them.
Isn't your brain really just electricity?
Isn't there a way we can maybe put it on a battery of some kind and then just,
you know,
put it in the back of your head.
This might be the dumbest size conversation at all times.
If the scientist is listening to this right now,
like I don't talk to Steve Listens to the podcast sometimes.
If he's listening to us right now,
I'd like you fucking eat it or he's just like,
Holy Shit.
You figured it out.
Battery brain batteries.
No,
I don't.
I don't hate anybody out there who's successful.
John Edwards.
Thank you John.
Thank you.
Have Fun.
Get Ya.
Nice.
Beautiful.
Um,
yeah.
That guy,
John Edwards,
I mean,
he's,
he's got damn ridiculous too.
Everyone's ridiculous.
There are no more ridiculous than Al Sharpton.
He's,
he's just like them.
They're all the same.
It's no big deal.
It's not,
it's not bad.
It's just,
it is what it is.
It's anybody that puts themselves into that,
but sort of nomination.
You know how you get rid of the whole Sharpton and Jesse Jackson.
Oh,
what an envelope.
That's what I love about,
yeah.
Come up black.
This motherfuck preach it.
That's his answer.
Thank you.
What do I need to do?
Just go away.
Yeah.
And they just a fucking piano and I don't blame the legal shop.
I'll,
I'll yell and scream until somebody fucking,
here's me.
Yeah.
They get contracts.
I don't have any problem with it,
man.
It's extortion.
It's a part of the game.
It's,
that's what it is.
It's a part of the game.
You know,
if you want his endorsement,
that's what he's,
it's,
it's a business.
Okay.
Nobody rides for free.
He likes shrimp cocktail.
He likes flying first class.
You know what I'm saying?
Why and why shouldn't it is a man of culture and he's,
he's so famous that he's sort of given up on completely like saying all his
words.
He's like given up on pronouncing them everybody else's way.
Like,
like they used to play that on,
was it Conway and Steckler I think?
Yeah.
Conway and Steckler in La used to have this thing called,
it would be a game called,
what would Jesse Jackson say?
I apologize if it wasn't,
if it was someone else
and I'm crediting to them because of my shit memory,
but I believe it was kind of weighing Steckler who are really great guys who had
a radio show in La and I think they might still do on on am,
but a,
they would play a Jesse Jackson clip and then you would try to try to figure out
what the fuck he said,
you know,
the people would call up and they would give up their guests and everybody was
wrong and then he would say,
what do you actually,
what the actual words were.
It was hilarious.
It was like people really could,
couldn't understand them.
That's how bad ass Jesse Jackson is.
He says his own words,
his own way.
You know like Mike Tyson.
Everybody does fuck them.
No.
What do they really want to talk about this?
What is it shady morph going off on me.
Is He still on his Twitter?
He's still going off.
All right,
go check out Jay Morrison.
He's saying all these things right now about me.
Like one he said I offered you a job.
You lied and said I asked you to buy me shit.
Weird obsession more has with you Jay.
More a just to attack you out of nowhere on Twitter.
I wasn't for higher and maybe he's not talking about me.
Comics leave you because of you.
You're not respected by your peers.
Change Your label name to exodus.
What?
Why you respond to that by even respond to that because it's weird.
It's certainly weird.
It's unhealthy.
Weirdest thing ever.
You you grow up,
you know watching Jay Mohr and movies,
you've never met the guy once and now there's a guys have assessed the value.
Well,
I don't know why he is,
you know,
I don't think Jay is a bad guy,
you know?
I know.
I don't know.
I know people have had issues with Jay and I know you've had issues with Jack
and I know I have never had an issue with Chai,
so as far as I'm concerned,
you know,
me and Jay more cool.
I don't like that he does this adult like I,
but people are crazy.
People that are comedians are crazy.
There's a percentage of whatever the fuck is going on in your head that's just
not right.
It causes you to say shit.
You shouldn't say it causes you to react to when you become,
you're an impulsive person.
I mean these are,
there's things that comedians do that are right here.
Right.
[inaudible]
you know,
it's this,
the beauty of this,
the beauty of the animals and it's imperfect wasn't,
he's not a bad guy though.
Radio station.
No.
I don't know if you wanted to talk about,
I don't know.
I don't know if it's true.
Yeah.
Sorry,
I can't say what else.
Go on the blog,
but here's my point.
If you,
if he's like spending his time and effort lashing out at you like that,
you know that's not healthy.
Yeah,
but that other things true.
They need to doing it to you also.
I don't know if it's true flirting.
I don't even care if it's protecting him.
The guy's going crazy on me.
I haven't said one to think too.
I'm not protected them.
I'm just letting him be himself.
I'm letting everybody be themselves,
man.
It's no judgment sort of.
That's such a weak thing to say.
No judgment because he better judge things stupid.
You know you a lot of things that you'd need to judge.
You can't just walk around and say,
hey man,
no judgment.
You're being a butterfly right now.
You though,
Katie,
I'll try to be a butterfly as much as I can,
but it's not in my nature.
Jaymar if you are listening to this right now,
I don't know why you're freaking out anymore.
Big Hug.
I think you're a very talented actor and a very fine standup comedian.
There's no need for all this nonsense.
What did you just posed?
Cares.
Tell him.
He's probably,
if he's listening right now and he is,
he may be very well.
We love you Jay.
Get it together.
Hey Jay,
here's an interesting thing that the month before,
uh,
are you going into history?
No,
no.
The month before Tom Sager and Christina [inaudible] escape.
I left death squad.
Uh,
I said,
hey,
we should get Jay more on a podcast.
And Tom was like,
really?
You do that?
I'm like,
yeah,
ask them.
So ask Tom about that.
I have no problems with Dj,
so I don't know why you're freaking out.
Okay,
so let's do a podcast with him.
Maybe he wants to do a podcast.
We can do like a east coast,
west coast comic beef would be Clive.
If Tait Fletcher comes with me,
that'd be awesome.
And it went no fucking Jay.
More karate.
That's hilarious because that's still works,
right,
Jay?
Mohr karate would still work.
Yeah,
I've been doing karate in Malibu at this place.
Yellow belt.
What is,
what to yell about that?
Hi.
It's for a little girl.
It really little kids get yellow if really that's not a real thing.
No,
it is.
It's the,
it depends on every,
the belts,
different racking systems.
But in Jujitsu,
yellow and green are just for children.
Well then that was an awesome joke.
I was the best silly belt you can come up with.
But if,
uh,
you know,
in karate there's,
there's different ones.
Like some of them go like yellow,
they go white,
always white to yellow.
The way taekwondo would go as white to yellow,
to green,
to blue,
to red,
red to black.
Brown.
No,
there was no ground.
There was no brown.
It was red to black and taekwondo.
Um,
but yeah,
the extra,
then I added the two extra belts.
The milk get to your fucking 90.
Yeah.
This is,
they got all of them and Polenta.
They got all different fucking,
what's that color?
But genuine HSA,
but budget the belt.
Now in Jujitsu,
they had all these belts and get you for an extra yard.
Stick those cards.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Hysterical.
When you join,
most,
especially taekwondo is the Koreans figured out.
They said,
fuck this shit.
I mean all slipping here.
Like there's a gym or we'll share,
we'll show it by labrea.
You have to pay them.
So you a black belt up front,
don't take monthly payments.
They have the three year acceleration program.
Are you paying for three years of suckers walking?
Then give them,
you know,
eight thousand nine thousand with a check and they joined for three years in
front.
Not knowing the unknown,
not knowing the Mayans are showing up in the fucking six months or whoever the
fuck they pay for three years for an accelerated plan.
And at the end of the three is they get a fucking black belt.
Wow.
They have that today.
That exists.
That's kind of crazy.
You know,
even Greg Jackson had it.
The fucking color belt system to is,
is going Jyutsu and shit like guide Jujitsu's.
Everybody's adding a call,
a belt,
you know.
Fuck it.
It's an extra yard.
Stick out to you.
Well,
I don't know.
No,
so I've only go for it.
Are actually charged.
Greg Jackson.
No,
I'm just talking about window.
That was a big thing,
man was charging for belts.
Oh yeah.
They charge you for testing belts.
If you fail the patch,
you know they work.
Those Koreans ain't fucking around no more.
They got federations,
they put together federations and associations and they bang you,
you know that bringing and you don't want give a seat.
Like when they come over and all of these white kids get together and that bound
at the grand master and the guy don't speak no Japanese and no car,
no English.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
He's got like a transplant and they're like,
you know,
welcome him to our school.
You know,
thank them for coming in the fucking Koreans.
Like suck my Dick.
Where's my check?
You know what I'm saying?
I didn't fly here to fucking give you a yellow belt.
You fucking suck is give us the look on their face when they fly over there.
Like,
I can't believe I did this for the small fucking nickel.
Come over here to see these little white kids doing form number three.
I need this shit.
They would always bring masters.
Yeah.
They always bring masters and they don't speak no English.
And we as a society,
we bow like there was a big deal at our taekwondo school when,
uh,
Korean master would come on please.
Those fucking people lose their mind is the master.
We work on our farm and we polished the mirrors so they're all shiny shit.
That dude don't give a Fritchman fuck.
He smiles and he nods and he fucking does everything.
And on the way out,
you see him get a big old envelope.
It's so interesting how when we were kids that um,
martial arts became directly connected with like Asian men,
like these Asian men,
these Asian men were like super respected as being like the greatest martial
artists ever.
You know,
that's like,
that's an interesting thing to say about their culture.
That before anybody had ever figured out fighting,
everybody was terrified of like black belts.
Everybody was terrified of karate,
Blah.
Bousquet a Bolo,
Bolo a muscular fucking Chinaman come and actually with a black fuck,
I had traps I hit that motherfucker stole walking around Hollywood yoked.
I've heard that a couple times that he used,
he hasn't aged.
He still does movies from time.
They still paying them to go to Bulgaria and shit.
Wow.
Still get to check the other guys around too.
I heard the guy that had the cut on his face when that Bruce Lee kicks through
the fucking toe rope wall.
He's around.
I'm gonna have to super foot Wallace.
Bob Wall is a real estate guy.
He,
he owns the building that my dentist,
uh,
has his practice in.
And so,
uh,
I uh,
I met him at a,
a couple of different,
it was good.
Yeah.
He looks good,
right?
Very nice guy.
Yeah.
He was telling you,
he'll tell you the old days about karate and you know,
you know about his spinning back kick,
you know,
and all the things that guys are doing wrong and MMA,
it's awesome to hear,
you know,
it's very,
when I talked to you about it,
you're receptive to what we talked about.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
Lauren,
Joe and now I went to his father.
Now what?
I went to his father.
This was the success of the Green Hornet and me get hit in the head and central
park because when the green one,
it came on,
American kids were starting to lose their mind.
People don't remember,
I go deep with this shit.
I go deep.
And all of a sudden it wasn't Bruce Lee,
it was a movie by the name of five fingers of death that the guy's palm would
get red at the end and he would hit you with the,
you know,
with the iron palm technique.
That was the first one.
And then,
uh,
which whatever,
we're going to start arguing fist of fury,
what the American name is,
Chang,
whatever the flux that first one came out where he's in the factory and it's in
Thailand.
And that was it.
Like I remember like even then there was maybe a Jujitsu school in a tristate
area,
but it was basically goes,
you karate Galician rule wing Chun Kung Fu.
And it just blew up.
Well,
he made a bluff.
It just made a bunch of people.
He made a bunch of people want to be like that solemn,
quiet guy who says nothing and sit in the back and waits for trouble to come to
him.
You know there was like a,
a silent mysterious gave you this quality.
Yeah.
What was the biggest obstacle?
The biggest admin and all the kids magazine wins.
Don't get sand kicked in your face.
All right,
Joe Weeder for a dollar 99 Joe Wieder would send you a poster that you hung on
your wall with all the techniques you had to do the lift and be strong in 14
days.
Plus he sent you a trophy for an additional dollar of a guy like this with a
chicken hanging off of him at the beach.
You don't think I own it?
That mother fucker take time.
You want me to bullshit you?
I had 10 of those posters,
Joe.
We'd was the shit when we were kids.
When I was in high school,
before I had taken tag window,
there was this one dude,
and I'll never forget this guy.
He was a,
he had this girl,
he was from another school and he had a girl that he was dating from our school
that was really pretty,
she was one of those pretty girls that didn't get recognized as being pretty,
but she couldn't sort of snuck through because she was kind of [inaudible] but
she was really printing.
And so this dude came by to,
uh,
to pick her up at school and he was like,
obviously like being looked at by all these kids from this school that you know,
he didn't belong to.
So he had adopted this like really intense sort of posture and he,
you know,
he had a,
like a Jean Jacket on and he was practicing karate,
practicing karate like on our,
in our school,
like there's like a little patio area,
you know,
there's like a little,
little,
a breezeway in between buildings as you're walking from building to building to
go to your classes.
Not a patio,
but you know,
just telling an open grassy area.
This is motherfuckers out there throwing kicks and kicking his hands and shit.
Doing a lot of these like inside crescent kicks kicking his hands and making
this loud noise and looking really intense.
And I remember thinking like,
wow,
like what a weird guy.
And I was thinking,
man,
I wonder if he really can fight cause I didn't
know and I couldn't.
I had,
I hadn't figured anything out yet at that time.
You know,
I didn't really,
I had done like very little martial arts so I was,
I was maybe sort of kind of impressed by him.
I was like maybe this guy is like some crazy martial arts master but I'm my
boob.
Why is he smoking cigarettes?
You know,
this is weird but I,
I'm that guy.
I'll never forget that guy.
Cause as I got older and I,
I would go through my database of things that I saw in my life and seeing how I
saw people behave and whether or not they make sense that one always stands out
and it's like a glaring one.
Like what a weird God because somebody will just go up to them to smack them.
That's what's happens in those things.
Go,
motherfucker comes out and is having a bad day.
Like oh you'll find a yet.
Let's sparkle.
I went to a very easy high school.
It wasn't,
it wasn't dangerous at all.
It was Newton South High School in Newton,
Massachusetts and they bused in a lot of kids from uh,
from other schools.
But the kids were pretty happy to be there from the bad neighborhoods and they
were usually pretty cool cause it was a nice neighborhood.
It was in Newton was like real quiet.
So like the shit that kids are dealing with today in high schools,
especially in cities.
I mean that's just like a prison yard and there's craziness going on in high
schools today man.
And what they're doing to try to combat it.
I mean we,
we talked about that one a place in Connecticut that had done that raid on the
kids' classes and pretended there was a shooter in the building.
They,
they,
they were looking for drugs.
So they tell the kids that there's a shooter in the building and to get in the
corner of your,
your classrooms and huddle up.
Why didn't they just say something like,
Hey,
we're having a fire drill.
Yeah,
why?
You should have said they should've said,
sit down.
We're searching.
You're,
you're,
you know,
we're searching for pot.
Let's be honest.
Let's be honest about we're done.
But so saying that you have a shooter said,
but that's how crazy they are.
Know they,
I mean this is the kind of shit that,
you know,
we never had to deal with that kind of shit when we're kids.
When was the last time when we were growing up?
There was no school shooters.
There was no one like go into schools and shoot anybody up until Columbine.
That was like unheard of.
I mean there've been some mass shootings at the one that was in Austin,
the guy on the tower,
which was that there was a sniper,
I forget,
I forget that case,
I forgot what it was.
But there's,
there's hat has been some,
you know,
mass shootings and shit like that before,
but never like at schools.
I've never had problems like that at my high school.
Now in hindsight,
I'll tell you what,
my grammar school was alive and kicking and I had two kids and my seventh grade
class that today are in prison for murder.
One we,
Charlie gives you that.
I should've known that because whatever appointed would go by,
he would always get on top of his desk and shoot it down.
Like you would go
in his mind and him and his brother killed the guy with that bands,
this neighborhood that we know five corners because it got five goals.
I always knew like I knew kids like that.
See what we were in school,
they would hold you and grab a school to you with 16 so these motherfuckers,
we're just looking to quit.
So they would just sit in the back.
But in reality they was
just gangsters,
you know?
They would tell the teacher to fuck off and shut.
The teachers couldn't really get it together when they're 16 and they,
there was called the pilot program.
Once you were driving through the eighth grade,
they had a fucking send you the high school.
But these kids were in no danger going to high school.
They hadn't seen.
Now you have to be 18 with a consent and your parents have to sign you out of
school.
It's tough to quit fucking school today.
So it wasn't tough when we went to school.
You just had a sign in yourself.
16 parents didn't even have to sign.
Yeah.
So it's a different fucking world now.
They have to be involved for you to drop out.
You don't see no commercials with dropouts no more.
When we would kid,
you see in a lot of commercials with dropouts and hemophilia,
whatever happened,
the emo feel JAKKS and just moved the fuck on.
When I was a kid that was a hemophilia,
I bleed,
not TV.
Every 10 minutes.
Remember that commercial with himself with a needle.
Hi on my hemophilia.
What the fuck happened to those people they've done.
There's no more hemophilia.
They would just bleed to death,
prick them and shit.
I was always asking my mother and I haven't met Maya hemophiliac cause I don't
want nobody bumping into me.
We come to a Chinese restaurant,
I'm eating Sushi and next thing you know I'm bleeding the fucking that consume
Manson.
Remember that would have to the hemophiliac.
They just passed the fuck on.
What a fucking shit disease to have to just walk around like a water balloon.
You know?
Just hoping that nobody pricks your skin or you'll,
you'll leak out and you can't stop it.
You're going to put,
you do,
what do they do?
What did they did they have to know that evolved member?
They would.
That was the treatment that I get money and shit like that.
That's fucking nuts.
But yeah,
kit schools had chain.
Listen man,
I'm scared of high schools right now.
If I was a parent,
I would be scared if I was a parent at home,
but what am I fucking options?
I called the school and then what?
Then my kids are fucking Momo.
He don't know how to [inaudible] days.
I bet you there's software that can homeschool year where every day know they're
raise you kids are going to get dragged into it.
What am I so what about my social fucking net?
What about socializing with kids?
This is something you do.
You can't socialize with your brother and sisters all your life.
That's why the school learning relationships,
learning how to,
I'll agree.
Yes,
I agree with whatever.
I would go on fake dates with my kids.
You know,
it's like you were talking about a Altadena.
I have a friend that lives in Altadena has a beautiful home.
I mean his wife have three children,
Nice family.
My wife works with the wife.
I go over there from time to time,
they have three kids.
You got to see this block,
Joe Rogan.
What you and I would do as kids to have this block,
we would kill.
You know those blocks with a little slant?
Just a little one,
not a beeper.
You can make ramps.
You can do a thousand things dog.
You know how many times I've gotten on the barbecue?
There's not one kid on the street,
so I would knock on all the doors if I was a stay home parent,
like as a pan.
I go every,
all the kids got to get out of the house.
I don't want play stickball put a recreation for this block just for this block.
Half of you just don't fucking work in the afternoon.
Get these kids out of the house to learn social skills,
which is a computer is great and you learn a lot.
And you know,
when I was a kid they said if you read the New York Times for four years,
you got a better education.
If you went to college,
that was the big thing.
Fuck College.
Read the news,
the Wall Street Journal for four years every day and you'll learn more than New
York Times.
I'm sorry.
Now you're going to get these fucking kids out.
There's no kids at Joe Rogan drive around your neighborhood.
I'll give you a fucking dollar for every kid you say you come home bro.
But a kid outside,
nothing that's not even paper routes to teach a kid how to flip a buck,
which is the most important thing when a kid is 13 and 14 it is a weird time
that we live in the,
you can't just have your kids run around and your plan.
You've got to monitor them like a hawk,
like a fucking whore.
And when,
when we got lucky.
Really.
I mean it's,
you know,
I don't think it's just an la,
are they still kids on the street?
I mean,
now here it is completely different.
Really?
Yeah.
Ohio is just like exactly how it was when I was like,
oh,
hi.
I was like the 1950 [inaudible] America.
It's like a Tom Hanks movie.
Why?
It's like an old sweater that you'll put on sit before the fireplace in most
places are,
you know,
kids are more educated.
Yeah.
When I was a kid and you were a kid,
we had to fucking get her botanic encyclopedia looks up them up.
But that shit,
Joe Rogan Britannica,
we had a steal a page out of the library and bring it home.
We'll do a third paper.
Yeah.
Now all with a flip of a button.
I can,
if I'm 13 I find that what a blow job is.
Yeah.
I'll find out what the fuck fucking explosive is and how to make c four and I
can learn it.
I'm fucking line,
you know?
Yeah.
We didn't have that shit.
I don't want these kids in the fucking house.
They got to get some vitamin D.
Dot.
They got to get some satellite,
these fucking kids.
And now you've become a vampire.
Well,
I think it's unhealthy.
Certainly it's the way we did it was healthier,
but it was also more dangerous just to be able to wander around the street.
What,
how old were you when you were at monitoring anymore when you can just leave the
house on you?
I think it's safer now in some ways with cell phones.
How old were you?
Five.
Six.
You go in front of the house.
Oh,
so Dadeo they call it.
You stay right there.
Yeah,
I remember it.
No,
don't cross Broadway.
Okay.
I remember very clearly get in a fist fight with my cousin when I was five and
he lived down the street.
So I was wandering down the street when I was five years old.
No,
I wasn't even five.
I don't think I was like somewhere between four and five.
Okay.
But remember when you were wandering down the street,
this is Rogan down.
Mrs Rogan,
your mom was friends with Mr Mary Magic Katya that had the third blog down the
corner.
And she had a boy and three doors from her.
You had Mrs. Wilson and she had a boy.
Right,
so all those moms are watching you.
It was a network of moms.
Remember Rick Case?
What's that expression?
To raise a village.
You had people that were watching you so I could say to you,
eight,
you're going to go over by Joe's house yet.
Tell it when you're going over to,
Joe is have his mother called my house and we miss a scan.
We still put a scam together.
He's coming to my house.
I'm going to your house.
But there was little,
I see kids not,
I don't see him outside of that concerns me.
The next generation is going to be on computers.
Yeah.
They've got to be very intelligent and don't know how to fucking reprogram or a
bomb if they need to,
but the social aspect of it,
we're going to get lost socially.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I hate to say it.
Yeah,
but you can't fucking homeschool a child.
I wish I could full time so he wouldn't be out.
You know when your kids leave to go to school now you have to have a fucking
doubt,
but so our parents believe it can happen.
I think a fucking happen.
We just,
Joe,
we were so lucky.
We were so fucking lucky.
You know,
I can sit here and tell you I've never been fucking,
one time a guy went for my dick when I was in the eighth grade,
I could tell you all the times that she could have happened.
Those stories I took about peep shows stick in my head that I was in the eighth
grade brother.
I was in eight grade.
I'm 42nd street somebody cause he just grabbed me and took me in the back and
butt fucked me the debt,
you know,
I mean I was playing three card Monte on 42nd street and 20th she returned to
the phone.
I swash we turned it on to do the interview with the computer guy.
It's just a very fucking weird how I was just very lucky compared to a lot of
people were both very nice.
You've got a call from hard to engage AFLAC,
AFLAC representative.
The Marshall Plan,
Bryce.
Oh,
have you seen the,
these photos of Rihanna cutting lines of cocaine on her body guards head?
What?
Yeah,
check this out.
It's a,
it's on a LB times.com and supposedly it's Rihanna like doing is,
she's like sitting on,
what does that call it when you're sitting on the person's back?
Are you piggybacking piggybacking shoulders.
And he's the bald head guy and there's just photos.
I've heard like the big pile of cocaine on his head and she's just cutting up
lines on it.
So allegedly allegedly,
that also looks like it could be like cheese and she's got a Dorito chip in her
hand.
Yeah.
Maybe she's eating some Chili con case in finding clarity.
Kind of the bottom looks like cheese to me.
Finding,
sorry.
That's cheese.
Jodi is,
Geez.
No matter how you look at it again,
I'm sorry I fucked a rash.
She went back with that fucking dude with Chris Brown.
Yeah.
They're friends again or something.
That's crazy.
I don't think that's [inaudible] he fucked up for sure,
but I think yeah,
but I think uh,
he maybe he learned from that fuck up.
You know she's got a great fucking ass.
She really does.
Who knows,
man.
What am I speculate?
I speculate way too much on this goddamn show.
[inaudible]
it's too much.
Goddamn talk.
Fuck it.
We should have at drawling podcast where just all draw.
I was talking,
what the fuck are you talking about?
That is the dumbest idea ever.
We should have a podcast that people listen to what we're just drawn.
Show your things to the people.
Cause pause a bunch of,
one part of the Joe Rogan experiment is to let people know about higher
consciousness.
You know you showed me a little pen that you had.
So I want to show people how we're doing.
Is the camera on,
you know,
a little fucking sticker you had the other day.
This is what's going on right now.
And I didn't know about this Joe or these guys tried to turn me onto vapor years
ago and I didn't like it cause you got to cut the wheat with the scissor it and
put it a little fucking thing and add a smoke 29 buckets and then my buddy
turned me on for this.
Do you Rica fucking vape gun,
right?
It comes in a little package and an eighth of weed in this tube can show you
actually smoking.
I can't open it to that citizen.
And you go like this,
you take this off.
Yeah.
And you take this fucking two people and you put it in here.
This is like you're putting together a silent day and you go like this Jesus
Christ,
that contraption and you were looking at [inaudible] like a tiny lightsaber.
That's how we're doing it bitches.
So while you're waiting for that Canadian,
but to come down I was smoking Skywalker.
Oh g and it's an indycar.
They have an old fucking sativa the boot to listen.
I'm going to blow that in the store.
This is faced next week.
You know what I'm saying?
That's how I'm rolling.
It doesn't smell like anything.
Nothing,
nothing dog.
This is the fucking future.
And I'll tell you why I'm here with this fucking thing.
I be a strictly honest with you.
I suffered from high blood pressure when I had the lease swelling.
I had to go to the doctor every day.
So I said,
let me fuck with his doctor.
Shaw was just smoking that before I would go to the doctor,
do I?
When I'd walk in,
it was one 30 over 80 like a motherfucker.
So this vapor isn't really affecting like my smoker.
When I would smoke in the morning,
walk into the doctor,
I'm walking in that one 60 over a hundred percent I'm smoking,
they're heavy duty.
Boy,
here's my problem.
Here's my problem with them.
Is that that uh,
it does,
doesn't still,
it seems for price wise,
it just doesn't seem like I'd rather have a real joint
$30 $30 I got a date,
the last two I've smoked the last meal a week.
What was the last time you had an eight?
Even less than a day.
It might actually pot in the thing.
No,
it's it's hash oil.
That's right.
30 27%.
They have it 31% for,
Oh gee,
they have a 27% for Sky Walker.
This is like smoking without the stems and the seeds because you see what Obama
said recently,
what we say done.
Oh good.
Joey smoking from the fucking vaporize it
no best.
It's,
he was talking,
there's a rolling stone article where uh,
the interview them and they asked him about pot,
asked him about what's up with the crackdowns on pot and he said that although
we're not going to go after the person who's using it to,
uh,
alleviate some symptoms for a legitimate medical condition,
we're not going to go after them,
but we're certainly not going to allow large scale marijuana operations and that
it's still an illegal federal drug.
Federally.
It's illegal even though it's medicine and I think it's like 16 different states
now.
Right?
Isn't it
anybody,
Brian,
I haven't seen a center use streams that we don't get paid.
Yeah.
Joey,
you can't,
can't smoke that thing on the air.
I ain't smoking.
Think get matters.
They've been mad at us.
Jesus,
dude,
I'm sitting there for an hour.
The thing is,
we become friends with the dude who owns,
I love to too.
I respect the guy that's local.
Are they?
I'm just,
you know,
tell them the truth is the Joe Rogan pockets.
This ain't got me this fucking Cuba saying,
I got a medical marijuana license.
What,
what,
what?
Speaking to communist Cuba.
That,
uh,
Hector Lombard signing,
he's going to come to the UFC.
That's going to be crazy.
I'd dude's a bombshell.
Washed all his fights at Bella [inaudible] and he was supposed to come to the
UFC a long time ago,
but there was something they couldn't work out.
God Damn,
that guy's good though.
He's scary.
Scary dude.
He throws bombs,
man for your mom's.
Oh,
he's fast too.
He's fast.
He's got fucking hammers in the hands and he's a real good judo guy to real hard
to take down.
He's an interesting fight.
It's going to be interesting to see him step into the high levels of,
uh,
of the,
you know,
the UFC middle weight division.
I don't know.
They don't think they've decided yet,
but it's going to be someone good.
I'm sure.
You know they're going to put them right in with someone real good.
He's a bad motherfucker though.
There's a few guys over there at Bella tore that are really good.
Eddie Alvarez.
That guy's good.
He just been shit jokey.
He just,
yeah,
he beat Aoki.
And then Mike Chandler,
the dude who beat him,
he's fucking good to man.
That kid's a beast.
That kid's really good.
He's,
uh,
his fight with Eddie Alvarez was crazy.
That was a nutty,
and they caused Alvarez and there's the lucky fight to leave to go to camp,
you know,
so it wouldn't be distracted when they know their stuff from,
his home life to really dedicate himself for six weeks.
So he went down and he was,
I think he did some training with the blacks,
aliens.
And uh,
he,
uh,
he looked fucking tremendous.
He,
he was just so focused against Aoki.
Speaking of tremendous,
that card Saturday night.
What a great card.
How good was that?
Good at it from a to z.
From Travis Brown to the fucking,
yeah.
Matt Brown fight to,
to,
you know,
to fucking mad harmonic mark homenet getting jumped like that by the Filipino
when they had them on the side with the Q tip of his nose.
He looked like my friend Ed was saying,
why would a joint this mouth?
He really fucking did I call it Edward,
right for the thing,
like,
are you watching this Filipino?
He's like,
yeah,
that mother fucker took it.
Dominic.
I mean,
there was some Great Rory Macdonald.
I mean there,
which is great fucking fight,
you know.
So thank you very much for taking this Jon Jones Against uh,
our boy Rashad Evans.
We had a great time that we not ready.
Yeah,
that was awesome.
That was awesome.
Jon Jones ever fight,
uh,
Silva Anderson Silva?
No,
no.
He's definitely not fun.
But it seems like those two together would be like watching the matrix.
I mean,
they both seem very calculated how they fight very like a couple of steps,
uh,
faster than the other guy almost.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
I see what you're saying.
A lot of people want to see that fight,
but Anderson and him,
there's a bunch of issues.
One Anderson is a 185 pounds.
He has no problem making 185 pounds.
That's his weight class.
That's the way class.
He's been a champion and although he's had a couple of fights at two oh five,
you know,
he fought
forest Griffin and two oh five.
And um,
he uh,
also fought James Irvin at two oh five knocked both guys out here.
It's not as natural way.
What does he walk around?
Can you just get heavy?
Probably walks out around around that about tool fine.
Maybe even bulked up a little bit to get up there for a James Irvin and for um,
Forrest Griffin.
But he definitely looked like a little thicker.
But the,
the issue is like,
he's really a much smaller guy if they were really the same size when he's,
when he's fighting at two oh five,
that's really is what he's weighing.
He might wait to 10 and it gets down into a five.
Jon Jones is like lean to 30.
He's a lean athletic two 30 and he died himself down.
And then,
you know,
he's very disciplined and then cuts the weight and then gets on the scale and
then he's good and he can make two oh five.
But Anderson Silva is never going to be a lien to 30.
You know,
they're just different frames.
That said,
it's still exciting because Anderson is dangerous off his back.
He finished his guy's off his back with triangles and things along those lines.
I mean,
he did it to Chael Sonnen.
He did it to Travis Luter who is a fucking killer man.
Travis looter is a vicious Jujitsu guy,
like one of the best in the,
at at the time,
like in one of his,
um,
when,
when Travis was going overseas and he was competing in like Abu Dhabi and those,
he's like one of the best Americans at the time.
Like Travis looters has really high level Jujitsu and Anderson Condom and a
triangle.
I don't care how tired he is.
I'm not catching him in the triangle,
you know?
You know what I'm saying?
Like I,
I couldn't imagine in my wildest dreams Kaching Travis Luder and trialed and
Anderson,
Ken Anderson can catch really good high level guys.
He's a legit black belt and I think people sleep on that,
you know,
like his,
his ground game,
his fucking good.
Even though Chael Sonnen was on top of him for four rounds,
beaten him up,
he never got fucked up.
His face was never cut.
If you look at him like he rolls with Shit,
he turns with things,
he's got good defense,
you know,
Anderson Silva's a threat to any man.
I just think if you look at like the size and you look at the attributes like
Jon Jones is such a good wrestler.
He's so good at getting guys down.
I mean even the way he,
Rashad Evans,
he grabbed Rashad Evans by his neck and tripped him almost like disrespectfully,
almost like disdainfully,
you know,
the way he grabbed it,
like choked him,
grabbed his neck and tripped them at the same time there's,
he's done some nasty shit.
He's getting better all the time and his,
his style is like the worst style for a guy.
Like Anderson,
like stylistically,
he's a really tall long guy who's was hard to hit,
who throws a lot of kicks,
separates himself by a lot of distance and he's a nasty wrestling.
Let me ask you this.
That's it.
I would love to see it.
That's two types of Jujitsu.
How you taught me there's Jujitsu and there's a major Jujitsu correctly discuss
this.
Like the shit that he does is basically as high level as it gets
because I never looked at it that way.
He was on the bottom for four rounds.
He didn't get caught.
Yeah.
So basically his fucking MMA Jujitsu is really,
well,
he knows how to take a shot too,
man.
He knows how to roll with things.
And then there's a video of him and uh,
Jorge Rivera,
um,
when they fought in cage rage and Anderson and him,
they tie up and Jorge can fucking punch man.
He punched his heart and he hit Anderson in a tie up with like four or five
clean punches.
Anderson just looked at him,
stared at him,
stand at them and took the shots.
It's like kind of creepy how good he is.
I haven't really dumb stupid.
What if MMA question for you,
what if Anderson Silva put on right before the weigh in he put on like really
heavy mercury fillings and his mouth.
Is that legally like why would you do that?
Just so he could be make weight without actually getting
out of here?
No,
I mean pick those fillings.
You'd have to be no,
I mean if he had ultimate over Brian Moment.
No.
Like if you have mercury teeth like around they way,
I don't know but one little piece,
it weighs a lot and he only needs to make what?
15 pounds,
20 pounds.
And if he had all mercury in his mouth,
like fillings are,
first of all silly.
This is this a real question of course it's not a real but no,
no.
I mean Megan,
would it be legal though led in your head?
Cause it was,
it'd be a filling if he had mercury fillings.
Look no one could stop you from taking a big lead pipe and stuffing it up your
ass to make weight.
So if you can help.
So I don't pick up that led up your ass because nobody wants to get heavier.
They want to be lighter.
No.
But if somebody like that,
that doesn't want to put on the,
I guess so what are you talking about Brian?
Or you're confused the shit out of me.
Cause you're,
you're,
you're posing this as if it's a real question.
No,
I just,
first of all,
you have mercury in your fucking mouth.
It's poisonous.
Like why not say,
you know,
if you could go to the surface of Pluto and come back,
it isn't that more of a like a long,
a longterm effect though,
being around mercury for a long periods of time.
Like you're getting knocked in the head,
I think like a week and having mercury in your face.
It's probably horrible idea,
but,
but I don't,
first of all,
if you had enough weight in your mouth to actually make you heavier,
your fucking head wouldn't be able to move.
Right.
It would take you a year to get used to the new dynamics.
We would take it out right after weighing in at night.
You could you take it out?
Why are you watching them,
Joe Rogan.
Someday you're going to shoot this fucking kid and the cops are going come and
you're gonna go.
I shot him and they're going to go,
we heard the podcast.
We're not here to shoot in the fucking bullet.
Why?
You answer them now?
But I didn't shut up.
Shut up.
Wait,
so wouldn't be legal to do that or would it be legal to do that if they wanted
to?
So they don't put your fucking mouth when you go up to her Mazzagatti whatever's
hurting.
[inaudible] feelings.
No,
he touches your fucking died.
He touches your are Muslim,
whatever his fucking name.
But I know the other Cox slapped.
I showed up with his cousin last week.
Remember there was tools at the name.
Oh,
Mario.
Y'all showed up with a cousin like date.
I got bad news.
I got,
I got to show up with my fucking cousin and he's on the ball here.
So now you got to,
I don't find they open your mouth right band.
No,
you're allowed to.
I fell he's but not when you look like fucking,
Nah.
The guy that used to catch 22 bullets and wild world of sports when we were
kids.
Does that get really tangible to his face?
I don't know.
Fucking [inaudible] fucking die.
You you fuck.
That's how he died.
They put the mouthpiece in his mouth and he would catch the 22 and splitting the
fucking fry pan.
How is it possible that Bro,
everything's fucking possible.
I mean,
could you imagine you're letting a guy 22 you in your fucking mouth.
Whoa.
How do your job?
She'd slipped out,
hit it,
hit it.
Brian,
what are you too will find the guy from the wild world of sports?
1973 cause that's in the old days he was together with closed the big karate
tournament in New York City.
It was Aaron close by getting shot at them in Madison Square Garden.
Aaron backs,
whatever his name is.
Yeah,
it was the [inaudible] gonna have a huge thing on a Saturday in July.
And what closed it?
The closer the headliner was him and then they put it on while water sports.
One year,
so it's gotta be on fucking Youtube.
I'm not making this up.
I do not know how the man died.
I thought somebody finally caught him with a fucking BB gun.
Was that the broken heart?
He was practicing and you know,
uh,
was a real legit karate guy.
That lot of people don't,
don't,
don't really appreciate Billy blanks.
Billy blanks is a real legit point karate guy.
Cause I,
I grew up in Boston and everybody thinks of him is like the Tae Bo guy.
I got to see him fight line a bunch of times,
especially back then.
He was so whoa,
these point fighting guys would get giant dude.
They were fucking huge.
They were these,
they were like NFL running backs like,
like to what do you got there buddy?
Wild rose sports.
What'd the guy shoots?
It's way too
[inaudible] that looked like it.
Brian.
That's fucking,
well you asked for it.
I want you to watch the answer to this first question here with a very sharp by,
and I'm going to see how long it takes you to figure it out.
There's comes from William Harris of Waterbury,
Connecticut.
Would you turn that off?
[inaudible] I read an hour a day.
He says,
you asked for catching a bullet with teeth.
No,
no,
no.
It's gotta be color.
It was the seventh.
Why does anybody do that?
What's that?
Who's impressed with you catching a bullet with your teeth?
I mean,
how does that,
how does someone's life go down that path?
Who swallows a sword?
Who Wakes up one morning and says,
you know what,
today I'm going to swallow a fucking sword and be a magician and code around.
How does that work?
Sorry,
where's it go?
It's just you,
you,
how you position your position or your neck just makes it completely straight
tunnel all the way down of right when you had someone who just fucking ran out
of the crowd and tackled you right in this sword was deep in your head.
Who watched the fucking HBO thing?
About the wall lenders,
but the grandson,
the fuck them while I'm doing,
and the guy killed himself in Puerto Rico.
He was gone and of the grandfather,
the grant Wallenda the dude was gone back to Puerto Rico.
He went back to do with his grandfather died doing
better yet.
He took his mom to meet them halfway.
Oh my.
The rope.
It was on Hbo Sports,
Hbo Sports.
You've got a fucking problem because they could make weight.
They could make ice skating look interesting on Hbo Sports.
Okay.
His mom and go hit the fucking youtube,
the flying Wallendas on Hbo.
The fucking great.
It's a family business.
They showed up.
They would practice without a net.
The grandfather stressed it.
You practice without a net because that's the only way you really fucking
learned.
The lenders are fucking interesting as shit.
Interesting.
I read about him years ago and I'm like,
where are these fucking much,
you know,
climbing,
putting up fucking wires in places where they just had the great grandson or the
grandson to the motherfucker that went to court and they showed the footage on
Hbo.
They show 1973 San Juan,
Puerto Rico.
Why Wireless Watch and he had been waiting.
Ah Shit.
He fucking dies.
So the grandson been doing it for years,
so now he's gone.
He went back to Puerto Rico to the exact same building at the Hilton Hotel and
he got out one side.
His mother got on the other side and they met in the middle,
and then they crossed each other with one fucking rope.
Joe.
Oh,
my mother almost lost it.
Grabbed her in the middle.
I gotta watch it tonight.
It's been on all fucking week.
The fucking flying Melendez ain't fucking around Doug.
They're like the Wu Tang clan.
That is insane.
The mother and the fucking sun passed each other on the wire.
Fucking Christ.
Right.
She started to lose it.
Oh Man.
He held her.
Hell God told her.
But she was fine that he went the other way.
He went the other fucking way and got all his hands.
Is that that isn't,
that's the most people that have a hard time and a stop sign.
You know what I'm saying?
These fucking Willis.
Imagine if we all lived on wires.
There would be the baddest motherfuckers of all time.
The world was just a series of wires and Plat.
You got to see the family practicing Joe Road.
It's like it taken the whole,
the whole platoon outside to the yard and walking across on ropes all
afterwards.
It has to be your whole life,
your whole life,
your whole life.
You can't fuck around with that.
Very brilliant and being so good at standing on a wire.
What does,
what a terrifying fuck.
Love makes you wake up in the morning and go,
I'm going to live on while I'm going to know and here's okay,
Laurie listed.
You want to go up the yard and get a treat and tied to the fucking rain gutter
and walk across.
I'm with you,
but if go to Atlanta,
check into a hotel and tie a fucking string across the street.
Walk across where?
Where do you get your balls?
Where the flooding,
when you get your balls from,
tell me.
It's just some people just always want to take things to the next level,
next level.
Even to the point where it's not,
it's not a smart thing,
but we want to find out what people can do.
I know where you got your boss from where?
That's right.
Motherfucker.
Wait,
look at that.
What are you get you fucking Joey do you can't show it on Ustream,
Brian and now obviously no Google hand.
Did you see that?
Did you see the new cover to put a new one
up to dancing?
The first cover Joey put up on Facebook was his balls and the the title is where
I got my balls.
That's the title of his documentary and one of those veins looking like the risk
and you send me some thick blood and all this.
Some big fucking done.
It was just like they did like,
like it was a road that had been shut down.
The fifties get fuckers,
just carbs
fucker.
Any mother fall over?
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
pumping.
Pumping.
You're very fiery.
Manage idea wasn't the flavor going through your body.
You know how we'd do it?
Flavor refund.
You've had more nicknames than anybody I've ever met in my entire life.
They were the only ones that I ever allowed a man to have their self imposed.
I've had friends that have tried to call themselves something you like,
shut the fuck up.
You're not the black Hornet or whatever,
you know,
whatever the fuck you trying to be.
But with Joey Diaz,
it was always mad flavor.
Planet Rock.
He was planet rock for a little bit.
Fat Babies here,
you know?
Yeah.
Mitzi with your fam pain me.
Oh,
so handsome.
She wanted to lick my nuts out.
It's,
yeah,
I love you.
That was a,
yeah,
it was,
it was really too bad.
We couldn't have gotten to that 40th anniversary thing.
I just want you guys to say or once camp man,
no one there that you would even know.
It doesn't matter.
It's just not my place anymore.
Not My spot to hang out.
I just,
uh,
I fucking,
I didn't take it to do it again and it's,
I have no idea why much animosity with the people that caused that issue.
This,
you know,
this,
there's always a problem whenever club is legitimately in the,
in the,
in the wrong,
in a situation like that where someone is trying to step in and stop some shit
from happening.
That's been happening a lot.
That's like,
it's really obviously bad and this is also going to get a lot of attention and
it's going to be good for the club because people are gonna want to come down to
the club.
Like all the things were in place for them to do the right thing
so I can never go back there.
Nah,
I'm done.
Done.
I would,
I wouldn't even consider you,
but I'm happy.
I'm happy for them and I hope it stays open forever.
It's a great club needs in 1972 they were doing,
you know,
which you have to really appreciate what you did and what you put after,
but you know,
people have to move on in life.
Yes,
exactly.
I feel great that I put in my time there.
It was a very important for my development as a comedian,
but after that's over,
it's over.
You know,
I,
I think it's important to have chapters in your life.
You know,
I would never,
I considered it a month ago just stopping in.
I think Ari was Dan reg band and I was like,
you know what?
You can't go back.
I always feel like I paid my tribute [inaudible] we did a lot of time there.
I did a lot of free shows there.
I did a lot of free shows that we pumped up on Myspace,
never got a penny from them and I replaced the sound system.
So I felt like what I did,
I was like,
I pay,
I,
I gave to what the comedy store was to make so I can leave,
I can leave it,
I paint,
I don't wish them ill.
And I at my soul is still one of the greatest clubs just to go in in all of the
world.
As far as like the history of standup comedy,
there's only a few places like the,
the comedy Magic Club in Hermosa.
That's a crazy one man.
You walk around those walls in the back and he's got,
first of all,
that Guy Mike Lacey,
he owns a comedy Magic Club is the nicest guy on the face of the amazing guy.
And he's got a back room where the comic sit and they feed you gourmet mashed
potatoes,
delicious desserts there and they're so generous.
And so kind that all the writing on the walls,
they have brick walls where comedians sign it.
They ask you to sign it the first time you worked there.
All the writing is positive,
all of it.
That's crazy.
Most clubs you go to and it's like,
you know,
Cock Fox sock Dick,
like all like all these favorite is the punchline in Atlanta.
I took a photo of it.
It was my favorite thing I ever read in a green room.
Said,
stop trying to be Hicks.
Whoever you are there.
God bless you sir.
There's very few things more annoying than when you see a dude trying to be
Hicks.
You're like,
Ooh,
no.
You smell it.
Comment.
Find your
own way.
Like,
oh,
it's so sad.
Oh,
do it.
Being at the store hosted for the 10 o'clock show for a year or two Joe noses.
You don't have any Hicks.
One of bees I see walking in,
there's always dead.
That night that you were there,
that Ultraman referred the kid and the kid came in and actually his second joke
was,
why would Jesus come back?
They'll that why people wear with crosses around their neck.
He went right into the second joke.
He didn't,
he a sergeant titty,
you'll think of bank yet stole the joke,
right?
The jump,
Bam.
And I'm in the Mitzi gone give him the fuck out.
Right?
Yeah.
That'll often went up to her to do.
I tried to be cute,
like get home from referred me,
but he's right.
I shouldn't belong it.
You just did a stolen joke.
Obvious one.
You didn't even fucking try to hide it in masculine.
Yeah,
well that's,
that's,
that's always going to be the case like that.
But the amount of people that wanted to be Hicks because he,
he had such a weird impact on comedians more so than any comedian than I'd ever
seen because no one,
no comedian made you want to change your behavior the way Hicks did.
Like Hicks was so charismatic and so confident in what he was doing and his
material was so unique.
Like the subject matter was so unique that all these dudes wanted to start
acting like him.
They wanted to start,
they literally adopted his philosophies.
You could see it and when you talk to them,
they were like,
they were like from the Church of Hicks.
And I,
and I thought about,
I'm like,
Kinison never did that.
Like Candice who made you laugh,
but it was always ridiculous shit about like cadavers getting fucked and you
know,
and Jesus screaming when he's on the cross.
It was ridiculous fun stuff.
But Hicks literally almost enticed a school of thought and a bunch of people
started being like,
he is,
you kind of have the same thing.
Well it's very different.
I mean I,
I've unquestionably was influenced by that guy.
There's no question and I would never deny it.
Um,
I think,
I think every person influences every person around them.
You know,
I've,
I've been influenced by Joey.
Um,
I've been influenced by Dunkin.
I've been influenced by Ari.
I mean,
I think we all influenced each other.
But your style of comedy,
I remember when I first saw you,
it was very,
very like,
I've never heard anyone talk this kind of way about certain topics.
And it was kind of like the whole,
like almost on like a religion almost where that was,
it was so different than seeing,
you know,
like fucking Steve Martin with a fucking Dan Joe on the stage,
which is what I thought comedy was.
Well,
why,
right after my first series of mushroom trips is when I started writing shit
about the d evolution of human beings and where the pyramids came from.
And you know,
where society's young,
like I started writing shit that was just so much different than anything I'd
ever written before.
But it was a direct result of my own psychedelic experiences before that.
Everything I was talking about,
which is like simple base shit.
Cause that's really all I was thinking about.
I mean I might've had complex thoughts bouncing around in the back of my brain
that I could do,
couldn't figure out how to put together and to anything,
you know,
coherent that I could bring on stage.
But once I,
once I started doing mushrooms,
once I started smoking pot too,
that could just completely changed my comedy 100%.
Uh,
I think,
um,
that's been,
if I had to say what's the biggest influence in my career?
It's pot.
It's funny that,
you know,
people don't want to admit that,
but I think you have to be honest.
You have to be honest.
I mean,
I first so for sure have done the work myself for sure.
I've sat many an hour in front of the computer in front of a notepad and many
times on stage performing and many,
you know,
many travels on many different airplanes.
I've done all that stuff too,
but God damn weed helps.
You know,
you could do a lot of the work,
but we,
we'd most certainly helps.
It's,
it's comedy for it.
Steroids for comedy rather.
We should,
let's say,
it's amazing how I was going to tell you this.
We wanted the phone about a month ago.
We were talking and we were talking about the success of the podcast.
You know,
and if you really watch comedy,
if you're real student of comedy and you're going to agree with me,
we forget about this.
The fucking tape that changed comedy forever was Rodney Dangerfield to specials
with those 10 killers from Donald,
wherever the Hicks,
the nice look at what those 10 guys did in history of comedy.
Robert Townsend,
Roseanne Barr.
Dot.
Merera Bill Hicks,
Lenny Clarke.
A fucking Bob Nelson.
Yup.
You look at what those 10 guys did.
They change the Seinfeld.
Yep.
So I thought it was on that too.
Yes,
he did the joke with them.
How does the hair get on the shower?
Doesn't have his own life,
Dah,
Dah.
Nobody could reach her in the shower.
People try to call you in the shower.
He can't talk.
He's in the shower.
You know all that bit.
Yeah.
Look at,
look at it.
Look at the two lineups,
the lineups of brilliance.
Lenny Bruce,
Tim Allen on one.
No dice follows fucking Bill Hicks follows dice.
Yeah,
I remember that.
And it is the most,
if you're a comedian and you come to me,
well,
what do I watch?
What do I learn?
Just get that tape and watch it and over watch the change of energy of DyeCycle
a 12 and a bath.
I have a mic.
You know,
when his mother,
he discovers jerking off,
which is a great bit.
He goes,
my mother has a Migden.
Has it moved and years,
you know,
you want,
what do you want for dinner?
Uh,
spinach,
I came already that whole bit.
He destroyed and bill Hicks went up that Bro with his demeanor.
How you doing?
My name is Bill Hicks.
I'm from Houston,
Texas.
That means I play in places like,
what was that?
Enid,
Oklahoma,
I think give you my impersonation of Enid,
Oklahoma.
Woo.
It's inside the club.
You know,
he just goes up.
But that's the one where he did one of my all time.
This to me is my most favorite joke when he goes,
uh,
fucking Vincent Van Gogh cut his ear off to send to a woman that makes like a
desert rose.
It seemed like a booger.
That'd be,
he goes into that one and he goes,
he goes,
Vince,
really Vince,
what?
Susie called that to me when he says what soon as he called that he,
and then he goes into being,
listen to how its material then was hot.
You talked about working at a,
at a horror movie on Hollywood boulevard and how people would come in and sit
behind them.
I remember when I chopped off that guy's head.
Then he talks about when he used to work at a shoe store,
a woman's shoe store and try women's shoes on it.
But then he went into the bit about,
you know,
I had a love and she dumped me and some day when their kids are bringing home
rickets and dead animals that are back there and he'll be fucking earns viles
the phlegm and fat and will be coming over her face.
I'll be on TV doing this show.
And he took it.
He took an infallible position because most comics were the whites.
Dice Clay Angle,
forget I'm not going on.
And he went up there and he took that energy and each just weaved it right in
front of you.
And to me as a comic,
that is the most influential set I've ever seen because he took heat.
He didn't take a good set.
Watch it.
Yeah,
he took he,
he took a guy up there talking about pussy and cock Audi and fuck you up the
ass.
And Ricky Ricky,
what was the nursery rhymes?
I mean Diane fired fire.
He was on fire for that.
It was Lenny Clarke and before that it was dom Irrera.
Dom Irrera was hilarious.
You never know those guys there could be missing it on,
but they'll still tough.
They'll fight you a one on,
hey you,
you talking to me?
I'll fight you with one arm.
You know what I'm saying?
That's when he does that bit.
I love Donald Herrera.
How are you doing uncle Vinny?
You know me,
I got,
I got it.
This my ass hole hurts my wife,
she won't bust my balls,
but you know me.
I don't complain.
I can't complain.
I can't show play.
That shit is priceless that Lenny Clarke opens up.
Let me comes.
I hate doing my name is whatever he does.
One of my first [inaudible] ever got paid was a opening for Lenny.
Come on my second professional Gig,
but I always,
I always lie and say it was my first,
but he took us working with Lenny.
You know Joe,
he took a bunch of comics that were big in their regions because at that time
vice was selling out rascals.
GRANDPA's dice was killing them in New York.
Seinfeld was killing them.
Hicks
was killing them in Houston.
They had all come up to the candy store now and they will all the killers from
their region.
Bob And a word of mouth killers is what it was.
Kennison yeah.
I was like,
I was a part of the Boston word.
Right,
right.
Got You.
Got a chance to see what it was lying with killers these times,
but you know what?
If you look at it,
that's the same thing the podcast is doing for us and I gotta pray.
I gotta thank you.
Rodney Dangerfield at the age of 52 he had nothing.
He took these comics that were right there on the brink,
Bro,
and he made them stars because the next day they called fuck with candidates for
the tonight show.
It was all of a seven minute set.
He gave them light.
And look what those 10 comics do with their lives.
Think about it.
I mean the only guy that really didn't bust a TV show is dom a reverend.
He's still a damn good fucking comic dour.
So kills it.
Bob Nelson on that.
My name is [inaudible].
My name is what?
Shut the fuck up.
Get over here.
That's brilliant.
But you know bill,
I think he does well there's the connection with me there too.
Cause guess what?
If it wasn't for Bob Nelson,
I would've never haven't been suspended as my manager.
How fucking crazy is that?
My manager used to manage Bob Nelson and Bob Nelson and uh,
decided to,
uh,
he'd become a Christian and he had decided to have is a prayer partner,
become his manager.
And so my manager has said,
well,
all right,
well I've got to go out and find new clients.
So he came to Boston and just by luck I was going on stage that night.
I wasn't even scheduled.
I went on stage that night cause I had a joke that I wrote that day that I
wanted to try out.
So I asked them if I can get five minutes.
I'd only been doing comedy for like two years.
I was still like a scrub.
I'll still like a rank amateur,
you know?
So if it wasn't for him,
I woulda,
who knows where I would've been.
You know,
that's the,
the hardest thing with Comedians is that,
uh,
someone who's a got that comic mind,
that's not the best marketer,
that's not the best person for getting their name out there.
You know,
they usually like some of the really funny people we know,
like Brian Holtzman,
you know,
I fear a world that doesn't know about Brian Holtzman Ashtray.
I fear I fear a world that doesn't,
that never saw the brilliance of that guy.
Right after Susan Smith drown her kids,
that guy went on stage a week after that lady drown her fucking kids.
And it was a huge case all across the country.
He goes on stage,
he goes,
I had to a bad kids.
I had,
they didn't put away their blocks are,
they spilled their milk,
they sat that close to the TV.
Those kids won't be missed.
And you're like,
Holy Shit,
I've tried to get him on so many podcasts.
Like there's so many people like that.
That's why I love doing podcasts because I love getting people to see people
like Brian [inaudible],
Steve Brody,
Stevens.
Yeah.
Well your podcasts,
you certainly exposed Brody,
you know,
and uh,
the icehouse chronicles have and,
and you know,
having him on this podcast has,
you know,
and,
and golf and [inaudible] loves Brody Brody's just,
uh,
he's to me like,
just one of those little brilliant works of art that you see out there in the
world where you're just like,
you stumble upon something that's not like anything else.
And,
you know,
you got to learn to appreciate it.
But when I get out of Brody is all positive,
you know,
especially now that he's,
uh,
he's really feeling healthy again.
You know,
I get out of Brody is a nice guy who has funny shit to say.
he chimes in some really,
uh,
really like personal funny shit.
He's just a gem is a gem of a dude guy.
I used to know that motherfucker from Seattle and he's a guy,
he's just an amazing,
he's a crazy guy,
great guy,
but he's also a guy that's not the best at marketing himself and that's the only
reason the world doesn't know exactly.
Funny comic that mock up,
which a probably went home and got on my space at night.
You know,
you had to be funny by fucking making the racks in the old days.
You got to bang it out.
You know,
very interesting.
A couple of weeks ago you were saying,
uh,
you had uh,
talked to Stephen Parry,
Joe Perry on Twitter.
Yeah.
You were thinking of getting them on the show.
A Arrow Smith.
It was 1970 fucking for the Boston red sox where everything check 1974 in
Boston.
The hockey team was up there.
The Celtics,
what can I tell you about Devon 74?
They own the world and he has these five 30 mother fuckers rocking it.
And also they'd put two albums out and I have to get your wings.
Uh,
the rumor was that they were on heroin.
You'll never see them perform again.
And they released it.
Now they Brock's in the first cut of the owl,
he comes out and yells back and he destroyed music forever.
There was no,
there was no Twitter.
They should chop that up for a fucking Twitter,
no Facebook CD that this is no nothing.
Joe Rogan,
you had to do it with talent.
You had to make that much of an explosion in New Hampshire to fuck these mother
fuckers to come and watch you.
[inaudible] what else,
man?
I've always been a huge Aerosmith fan.
You have a minute.
You call home and you put out rocks looking at in a fucking rock.
Diamonds,
five diamonds,
five guys that didn't even talk to themselves,
to guys splitting I pesticides in the house and the drummer and the Bass player
talked.
Everybody else didn't talk [inaudible] sign your name because they weren't on
the fucking age.
You had to sign your name to book the studio,
which was the basement.
So you imagine me and you live in the same house.
We hate each other,
but we still in a band,
look,
Iraq's rocks rocked and they did this for rocks,
toys in the attics and something else.
Cause they got five hours.
Oh,
draw the line.
They got five,
five albums that I put up against any body.
Get your wings up,
put up against rocks.
I'll put up against anybody.
Bring it.
I'll put it up against any pink Floyd rocks.
Uh,
when they,
and when Joe Perry takes those heroin,
fucking put on nobody's fault.
Listen to Novo.
Listen to fucking up.
Oh my God.
I've been listening to all kings and Queens.
Oh yeah.
Not,
not the,
not the version on the greatest sets.
They chopped the heroine.
Get taught the long version and knew he had Joe Perry.
Fucking your soul taps.
Go Perry was a bad mother fucker.
You know,
there was a time when,
um,
Kurt Cobain killed himself,
that there was a,
something going on between Aero Smith.
It
was like Steven Tyler and Bob Goldthwait.
We're having some back and forth thing where Steven Tyler was talking about
pretty sure it was Aerosmith and they were saying that like Nirvana,
like was,
you know,
the,
the last thing they would give a shit about was,
was,
was aerospace.
And I remember thinking,
how can anyone say that?
Like Aerosmith,
they became ballads for movies.
They became valid for movies,
but there was a period of time,
you know,
walk this way.
I mean,
come on man.
Fucking bad ass came back to,
they were five guys that were strong,
so much on heroin,
even by the garage,
which was torn by the critics.
If you put it on,
it's a great fucking out.
It's a great arm.
That's when he left.
And I remember I went to see him and I went to see the Joe Perry Project Open up
heart,
opened up for the cheese at radio city again,
I was at a quail loot and I grabbed the fucking blonde by the ankle security,
almost fucking grabbed the d.
The guitar grabbed the pitch.
I really like that fucking [inaudible] bitch.
Oh,
that bitch could play.
You know it's,
it's funny because I read that after Tyler went on American idol,
everyone sold a bunch of albums but they only sold albums up to the loving an
elevator and all that shit.
Then fucking original the blood line.
These kids can't handle it.
You put on get your wings train kept rolling live.
They mix it into,
cause if he wasn't the train kept the row and that's never been done before it
start studio.
But it adds like what were they doing?
What was heart doing that made them so good when they're doing heroin?
First fucking two or three hours,
little whatever.
Not some great Sam Barracuda is a great man.
Fucking what about bro?
What about Oh girl,
listen to the words on that Bro.
It's about a girl who's getting drilled.
Yeah cause she loves the caucus.
She ain't coming home billboard.
Whoa for a lot.
I'm trying to understand.
Try to understand.
Try to track chat on the same [inaudible] she says that he's a magic man.
Mama.
That Dick is driving mama crazy.
Damn.
No Shit.
That's a dude who's just sending home the good.
That's when you're 18 and you run into a 22 year olds.
That's Ms. Fling a Dickerson,
thirsty ass.
If you've been like fucking a cub scout,
we just bang just draped.
Men loves to do that too.
They love to just leave a devastating impression.
Like you know,
it's almost like getting off stage when your dies going,
follow that nice like being 16 and fucking a girl and getting out of school.
She's right there ready to carry your books.
That made you late some pipe on that bitch.
That's an important thing to do to in a relationship,
man.
You got rock that check.
You never understood if it,
again,
it really goes back to the golden principle of life.
The more things you do that make other people feel good,
the better you feel.
Good.
Maybe just had a card trick that looks really cool.
You got a rock or you got to rock you.
Like when you,
I'm going to hire you on silent.
Your mother married to a woman after to six or seven years.
You lose that spark.
So every once in a while you get what you need to weed.
You got a piece of ass that's like every other week.
That's like just a piece of ass,
but every two months or every month you come home,
one night you pull up by the hair and rip the panties off and you get down.
You got a rocket.
You got to,
it's like Anderson Silva.
He's got to smack somebody every 90 days.
You got to smack somebody every 90 days.
You know what I'm saying?
That's saying this is Silva.
Did he say that?
Ooh.
Did Anderson Silva said you smack somebody every 90 days.
Don't eat those.
That's what he's going to attribute that to him via Joey D.
Even if he doesn't,
wasn't like,
oh,
well you will not understand.
I pop up block.
I bat smack in the face.
You don't know what the fuck is man,
but he's smack somebody in the face every 90 days.
That's what he does and it's itself is living the life man.
That's a fascinating cat right there.
No,
we missed out and I got to,
you know they're going to have that fight in Vegas now.
I know you got off the fucking Hook you,
but you better be.
I wanted to go to big,
I had a great time in Rio.
I know you had a great time of real,
but if shit would have fucking,
that's what I was worried chuck you,
they wouldn't get like,
uh,
what's that?
Charles Bronson for women was going to be a fight in Rio de Janeiro,
Brazil in an 80,000 seat soccer arena between Anderson Silva and Chael Sonnen,
the most anticipated rematch maybe in the history of the UFC,
the first fight,
four rounds of complete domination by Chell son and took him down always on top
ground and pound and drop and punches down.
And then the fifth round,
Anderson Catches Him with a triangle and come from behind victory.
Incredible fight.
Right?
Okay.
So they were gonna fight and they would have a rematch in the soccer stadium,
but all chill sudden does is talk shit about Brazil.
He's coming on the week of May 7th but we're out the date,
but he's going to be on because he's got a book out and if it's a child sign in
book,
I guarantee you with tremendous,
that dude is a funny motherfucker.
He in my opinion is the best shit talker,
the best fight promoter of any sport period.
If you knew that guy and he knew what he's really like and then you see like
what kind of a Ruckus he can stir up and how much clever shit he comes up with,
how great he is and answering questions and those Q and A's off the cost ticket
for Brazil.
So it all went well.
It went down.
This is what happened.
The Ulan has a meal.
Let's first capital,
let's scheduled for his attention.
We Chili Chili's don't take place in July.
I want to see it.
I don't want to see it though.
I want to see it in Brazil.
Oh,
you listened.
That's dangerous to prove a point.
Well you shouldn't have said nothing.
He most certainly shouldn't have said something bad about the country of Brazil
because when we tie something,
I have never seen a country as fiercely loyal as Brazil talk shit.
Now you gotta go down,
Bang,
love,
love each other,
love Brazilians,
love being Brazilian man.
There are,
there is so much pride in Brazil.
It's they,
it's like,
you know,
it was a lot like that too,
is Canadians.
There's a lot of Canadians who will come down here and they find out you're a
comedian and they're really excited to tell you about real funny Canadian
comedians like we've got,
you know,
can,
I has got some really good comics.
You know,
Jim Carrey came from Canada,
you know,
like they,
they're like proud,
proud to be Canadian,
but not as nutty as the Brazilians,
man.
Brazilians are they,
I've never seen anything like it.
I've seen guys fight in Canada against Canadians.
The Canadians,
even though they were rooting for the Canadian fighter,
for sure.
We're very polite.
For the most part,
to the American fighter,
whoever the fighter was from whatever country in Brazil,
they're chanting out,
you're going to die.
They're chanting.
I'm talking about a whole crowd.
The guy gets on the scale for the way in and they're chanting out this thing.
So I don't,
I dunno what the fuck they're saying.
And so I asked the lady,
I said,
what are they saying?
She goes,
they're saying,
you're going to die.
Wow.
I was like,
your whole crop,
the whole crowd scene,
you're gonna die.
And so then we're at the fight and it was,
um,
one of the dudes from,
from,
uh,
Brazil,
fuck,
I can't remember his name.
And he fought Mike Pyle.
Goddammit.
Coddle Punch.
Yes.
Ricardo Funche,
Ricardo Foche,
who actually,
I was trying to,
I'm getting confused.
I was connecting him with Gonzaga,
cause I know he trains a team link in a western Massachusetts with Gonzaga.
Um,
and,
uh,
Mike Pyle knocks him out and Mike Pyle is like bowing to everybody trying to bow
and they're booing like at the top of their fucking lungs.
Man,
they're going crazy.
By the time I get into the octagon,
he's saying,
I just want to say that I love Brazil.
It's an honor to be in this and that.
And they're chanting out something.
So it sounds like c Egon.
No.
See you got,
oh,
and so I asked the lady,
I said,
what do they chanting out?
She goes,
they're champing up for junior dos Santos Sugano,
and so I go,
oh,
okay.
That wasn't what they were saying.
They were saying fig I know,
I think is how you say it,
which means faggot.
Wow.
So 18,000 people were jetting out faggot to a guy who is bowing to them and say,
thank you.
I love Brazil.
I love it here.
Thank you very much.
Like they were just mad that he beat a Brazilian.
They are so passionate and nationalistic that if child son in one,
my God,
I feel be reasonable.
Why I was worried about you.
The only one I'm worried about you wouldn't Goldie,
you know,
I said,
yeah,
well they had a wall of security around him.
He was just in Brazil recently and they had a wall of security around him.
It's either Robert Armor.
Yes.
It would have been just like that.
I have to wait or you whatever was fucking bad noise.
Yeah.
Well,
it could have been,
man,
we could have seen him get a password.
That's not a joke.
That's all you.
Ah,
ah.
What happens on the phone?
Got a towel.
No.
Yeah.
That's all you would have heard,
I think from now on.
All UFC used Japan.
Yeah.
Japan was very polite.
Japan was the most polite place I've ever been in my life.
Have you been following this shit lately about the reactor?
Last couple days I've been following what appears to be an article that's
written on one of those fear sites.
It's like the end of the world's coming and apparently according to a lot of
people that read it on Twitter,
the science is not correct and it was.
It doesn't make sense,
but that said,
I'm just repeating shit that I read.
I don't really have any,
I hope not,
man.
I want to knowledge whatsoever,
but it doesn't seem like it's good.
I mean,
what's going on with that fourth reactor is that thing melting down too.
I read something about the fourth reactor.
I was like,
Jesus Christ is that a possibility?
Does that he imagined they have four reactors that melt down and turn that whole
place and just a a radioactive.
So two people are saying when that fear thing,
they were saying that California was already getting fucked.
Yeah,
well they're saying that we have higher levels of radiation than,
than ever before and they're attributed to Fukushima.
They're saying that it's getting,
it's in boulder,
Colorado.
They're saying it's a,
it's essentially all over the country.
You can't stop it,
you know,
it just,
it just flows over the,
the question is how much of it can we absorb before it becomes dangerous?
That's a question.
I don't know.
But they are saying that we are experiencing higher levels of radiation than
usual because of these Japanese reactor.
Is there,
I think it's the whole country.
Any kind of like on it type shit that,
that yes.
Help you.
Yes.
Potassium,
iodine,
potassium,
iodine is,
it offers protection to different parts of your body.
A,
especially your,
um,
your thyroid gland can be adversely affected by radiation.
How there's been a lot of thyroid cancers lately.
And thyroid disease.
I don't know,
something that's been since the reactor,
but I mean there's a lot of environmental factors and genetic factors that can
contribute to that too.
Right?
So you needed to have a zombie away for on it.
That's just that away.
Seriously keep you from getting fucked by radiation.
Yeah,
well I would so,
yeah,
maybe,
I don't know.
Um,
I don't know what the fuck the future of energy is,
man,
but it's real scary that something like that Fukushima Shit can ever happen
because we're looking at such a small time frame.
Okay,
we're looking at,
here's,
here's the earth in 2012 right?
Picture this in 2012 a hundred years ago,
there was no nuclear power at all.
There was nothing like it.
Okay?
That's 100 years ago.
They had not figured that out yet.
Just the idea that in a hundred years you can have Chernobyl.
You can have five mile,
three mile island,
you can have Fukushima,
you can have all those take place.
Huge,
gigantic disasters that fuck those areas beyond repair for a hundred thousand
plus years.
Just a fact.
You can have three of those inside a hundred year period where nuclear power
exists.
How long do you think nuclear power is going to last?
You mother fuckers,
nuclear power is going to last with thousands of thousands years.
You're going to accumulate a certain amount of these fucking disasters and the
more you do,
the more you're going to have unlivable spots everywhere in the world.
If you want your disaster,
there's your fucking disaster.
There's an almost inevitable disaster we don't know about.
What do we think that?
Well,
how about the storage of the stuff?
That's the real issue.
They don't know.
They don't know where to store the waste.
They store it in Nevada and that's one of the reasons why you get the gambling
in Nevada is that they did a lot of tests.
They did a lot of nuclear tests and they also did do a lot of nuclear storage
and so these deals that they've made a right on top of the Mandalay bay.
Even that shit.
Look at Van Nuys.
We might be breathing it right now.
You know what's crazy football?
Did you guys see that?
The kid from Japan found that in Alaska.
Yeah.
They found the soccer ball.
That shit's already there.
My friends,
that soccer ball didn't show up by itself.
We will then
send them proof that radiation is hitting our shores because shit north shore,
they've said,
they've said that they've already,
you know,
they,
they can actually track it in the Gulf stream.
They know where the radio,
you know,
cause they had a poor millions of gallons of ocean water on the reactors to cool
them off and they're still doing that.
They're still doing the same thing.
So they're just wantonly polluting a huge area of ocean to stop their issue and
there's no other solution.
I don't know how else they're going to cool it off.
I don't know what the fuck they could go.
I mean it's almost like they,
they need science to come up with some incredible innovation to stop the
meltdown of this thing.
Who would have ever thought that that's how a reactor is,
is that there's no way to stop it,
is that once you run out of power,
like literally you can't contain the energy and it just eats through its
containment cell and it becomes incredibly toxic.
Like who would have every thought that they would make something that seems so
likely to fail.
So likely.
What if it got hit by a meteor?
We're fucked.
You know,
really.
why would anybody let them build that?
It's almost,
it's almost like they had something and they were sure that they would have it
completely harnessed in 20 years,
but just launch it today and cross our fingers at the power doesn't go off for
20 years,
but in 20 years from now we're going to know how to deal with this stuff the
fuck we are.
We might not ever be able to figure out how to deal with nuclear waste.
It might be just one of those things know not enough,
but maybe not at least start talking half life.
So it's like a hundred thousand years.
Don't get not to mention that.
Or we have all of this radioactive shit.
What about all the oil that's been hitting the ocean?
What about the shit that happened last year?
All the shit accumulates.
Yeah.
This is all,
this is all effected off bucket cheat one way or another.
This will all this shit pollution,
oil in the water.
We're not catching a break from any fucking direction.
The only one who's really catch a break and limited fucking Montana where they
found the teeth of those dinosaurs.
That's it.
I mean not,
what else can we,
you can't drink ocean water to fucking 20.
We don't know what we're drinking two years ago.
They do the thing that there's drugs in the water that you drink,
you know,
small percentiles of uh,
fucking value or whatever the fuck they found.
You know,
which doesn't affect me.
I don't give a fuck.
It adds to my party.
But I'm just talking about this,
a ton of shit out there that we don't even know,
but that's what we know about.
We know about that.
What about all these?
What about when we talk about rocky flats and Colorado?
We did.
Those people were out there because they're making that up.
Those people were real intelligent,
aren't they?
And they said that shit was leaking for years.
They had proof of rocky flats.
So we sit here for hours and talk about bold and all this shit out graders.
But those people had proof that there was leakage update in that beautiful
fucking area.
We have you.
Have you ever gone to rocky flats when you drive to rocky flats?
You know you're somewhere that you're not supposed to be member of that show.
The hitchhiker on Hbo,
he'd be hitching and there's nothing out there.
Just flat land.
That's it.
How beautiful is Colorado one?
Have you ever seen a flat part of Colorado when you hit rocky flats?
The mountains a fall,
the fuck away and whole areas flat.
Very.
The air is thinner.
Like there's a little fucking guy in a security thing,
like an RBG by himself.
This is the entrance to like a Stephen King movie.
It's like a state.
It's,
it's like the continuation for this shiny,
like it's gray out there.
When you go out there,
Colorado Sadia like I've told you before,
boldly gets as much sunshine as a Wai Honolulu.
Hawaii.
Yeah.
When you go out to rocky flats and even feels gray,
it's probably the government man.
It's good.
I probably shoot that harp shit.
Now,
where's the place where you go underneath?
What's the name of that in Colorado for us has a norad,
I'm sorry,
normal rounds in Colorado.
Where is it?
Not Norad in Colorado.
Can they check for me please?
Yeah,
sure.
This nor gods in Colorado.
You know like when you go on bold Gloria,
where the fuck his door,
right,
exactly.
And they have a place to devil stomach,
bold North American Aerospace Defense Command.
How's that?
Norad?
I Dunno.
Defense Command n a underneath.
That's why they always said if you live in boulder in Colorado it's great.
But the first places I like going to get bombed,
it's going to be Colorado because you going to try to destroy norad even though
it's just a fucking,
they have 20 zero rads and we have more,
uh,
hire a fucking whatever one's now nor had was built.
God knows when.
I mean by now we must have other caves that are fucking stronger,
but they've always said that norad is one of the first places they'll take out,
look at it,
read about it,
nor had as one of the first Colorado Springs is located at Patterson Air Force
Base.
If you've ever been in Colorado Springs,
Colorado Springs.
He was like,
aw,
military man,
all military.
Oh military in 1985 the number one growing city in the country and number three
for crime at the same time.
The [inaudible],
Colorado Springs,
there's no fucking joke in any five cause I almost moved there.
That's how I ended up in boulder.
On the plane,
somebody say you don't want to go to Colorado Springs has a Gi town,
they'll get you boulder with some bitches.
It's a,
it's a Gi Gi talent.
It's also really religious town,
very religious.
Their religious Colorado Springs is where Ted Haggard is from.
That dude had that crazy minister and was winding up doing crystal meth and
it's probably easy to get religious when you lived there just because of all the
beauty around you.
You know,
you probably have liked.
Yes.
There is a maker of this.
This is amazing and gorgeous.
It's also easy to get religious in a,
um,
uh,
an army town.
You know,
that's just a fact.
I'm a military towns,
you know,
there's no,
there's no atheists in foxholes.
That's an old expression to Colorado.
It made me want to smoke more fucking briefing.
Yeah,
that'd be honest with you.
I became a reef ahead professionally.
I was always a reef ahead.
Once I moved to Colorado,
I'm like,
I get it now.
You're in God's while the fucking,
it really is God's country.
You know,
when you're driving through the mountains,
like I always just describe to the,
the feeling that you get is just like something,
if you're looking at the most incredible work of art,
if you looking at a beautiful,
like incredible work of art,
like that feeling of awe and inspiration and just a,
and then really a wave of happiness washes over your body.
That's what it's like when you're driving around in boulder.
I mean,
that's how crazy it is.
You know,
if you've ever seen core d'alene,
Idaho,
you had been in school.
This Jesus Christ.
Is it beautiful up there?
Oh my God,
Dude.
I looked at some photos online and I'm like,
this doesn't even look real.
These people,
there's a town up there and apparently it's like Alanna real like fat cats and
it's like,
um,
where's that one place in Wyoming?
It's like a,
a famous place in Wyoming.
I like Dick Cheney.
He's got a ranch and Cheyenne,
I dunno where.
No,
no.
Well how about this?
Let's,
I'll just type in rich people,
Wyoming,
but they all have this,
uh,
the,
they have like a,
a town up there where it's like,
oh,
like bankers and billionaires and shit like
that.
Come on,
I can't find it.
Which people live in Wyoming and Wyoming.
[inaudible] seven
Jackson Hole.
Jackson is Jackson Hole.
That's it.
[inaudible] we're all rich people live.
You know,
that's what they did and they pieced it together.
There was a spot,
you know,
we're,
it's like,
it's all like mansions and ranches and she ever looked,
you go online just for a goof and like look at real estate and different sounds
amazing.
I like to do that.
I like to say I went to Cheyenne,
I went to Jackson Hole,
Wyoming and my roommate,
not my roommate,
the guy that lived next door to me in Snowmass village and 83,
his father died.
So he came through it and he goes up in the bind that really needed like 600
bucks in my plane ticket.
I gave it to him.
I said,
don't worry about your father died when he came back.
He goes,
I really want to do something nice via,
he was the manager of sport.
Katelyn sport can lose a big ski shop and Aspen at the time.
And he used to get demos.
He's the guy who first taught me how to ski.
This guy did a lot for me and one day he goes,
I want to take you on a trip to uh,
him and his wife.
We would take me to a trip to Jackson hole ski.
At the time I was pretty decent on one 85 but I wasn't fucking good at all.
I say 85 180 you know your skis,
one of the fives,
two oh five so I was okay.
These motherfuckers took me to Jackson hole and my president wants to go on a
helicopter and jump out of a helicopter into snow and guys,
I ain't a straight fucking do it that you couldn't do it and I wouldn't feel
your smart.
Fuck you.
I should've done it.
Oh fuck yeah.
I shouldn't eat mushrooms.
And Jay was just 20 foot drop.
It was just a 20 foot drop.
And you're dropping into
doctor Steve,
my buddy 80 inches.
Yeah,
I fucked him this morning.
Are you?
You're jumping into 180 inch base of snow,
so you basically landing in 30 feet of snow.
Nothing's going to happen to you.
You're just going to go down a little bit into the mountains.
This when you shoot,
but that's the present you 30 feet of snow and you're on the top of it.
Who Know How fucking much based there isn't the top of a mountain of snow.
30 feet has got to be 20 feet.
It's those all fucking,
you know when you're going to look right now,
what's the base of Aspen?
They'll give you 114 inches.
Whatever the fuck they give you is debates are,
what does it feel like to be in an avalanche?
Imagine that.
I couldn't,
he was one recently where when you look back a mesh,
it's chasing you.
But you know when you go skiing,
even ski,
like I listened,
uh,
three years ago I shot a movie in Colorado and I went up there and they gave me
a ski pass for the day and it was great.
I got on the Gondola,
I put skis on and I skied
around the top and I was up there for too long.
I got oxygen,
sickness,
you know,
high level,
whatever it was to fly parks,
whatever it was.
You get dizzy and shit.
So I went down,
but my skiing days are over.
But if you ever get the chance and you're young and your knees and whatever you
eat a mushroom,
cause that's what those people do.
They mushrooms and go skiing.
Apparently a snowboarding is easier to learn snowboarding.
It's easy.
It's great.
It really is.
I don't think so.
When you went this last time,
did you see your children's ski?
What's your children's ski there?
Google too young.
I you were saying that they uh,
they call them ski bunnies and they take them when they're three and they teach
them how to ski and Hey,
you are 20 years old,
you've been lifting weights,
drinking protein shakes and here you all walking like a Zombie and these little
fucking four year olds go by.
You're doing Nightingale that stops you.
Shouldn't you feel like a fucking moron?
You're like,
look at the,
but there are lower,
they lower the gravity so it's easier for them to talk and,
but [inaudible] easier for me to,
you know,
lower gravity.
It took me three hours to walk from sport Katelyn to the lift,
bro.
I grew up in three hours cause I put the skis on.
I thought I was going to be like,
oh no.
I kept falling and falling and you're walking with the skis on the fucking Momo.
You know like trying to project ski poles.
The pole you are doing cross country.
Yeah.
That's a different type of skiing.
Skiing with you guys anytime you want.
No,
no,
no.
You Ski.
I grew up skiing.
He grew up ski club.
I neither he did when he was younger.
[inaudible]
it's just leaning left to right.
It's not that big of a deal.
When you're a kid and you go skiing,
you'd these a fucking nothing.
Get Carla just strong,
strong.
You just bounce.
Like I said,
you don't twist.
It's when you get old to that.
Don't skis cross you fucking history.
I never fucked with anything.
When I was growing up that involved the cold.
I didn't want to play hockey.
I don't want to fuck you.
I hate the cold.
I really enjoy is amazing.
I really enjoy it.
Seems like fun.
I had never done it in Jersey because why would you do it in Jersey?
Bravo says it's like close to sex.
It is when you're flying,
that wind goes and then you realize it's you.
Your body is like a car and you're just going to realize it's,
you asked and you'd see like all this,
like you're in the forest.
I think it's,
it's,
you can't trust myself,
man.
I'm too fucking impulsive.
There's what?
What happened to me,
Joe Rogan.
I would go jump off the Gondola and I would start skiing and go and talk,
you know?
But Brian,
I would talk and get great stance and I'd be balanced and all of a sudden I
realize I'm going a little bit too fast and I would fucking crash my own.
Like I'd be scared.
I scanned myself like I'm going to fucking fast white.
No,
no,
no.
And I fucked him.
Plow and tech.
I told you I would take out ski lines.
I would just take out a line,
talk to my fucking head and go for Brooklyn Woods.
You really
owe a couple dog.
I'm embarrassed to say it,
but it's easy to freak yourself.
It's easy to freak yourself out.
You Freak yourself out.
You're like,
what should people next to you?
And like they start goal
and you're like,
oh no,
no,
no.
Because you know what the results are.
How many times have you fallen?
You ski is two miles up.
The fuck is,
you got to fucking climb up with those boots and go get you don't know how many
times I've got a gondola with like three old and I call him God,
who was,
I'm sorry,
the lift.
You don't know how many,
what's the difference?
The Gondola has a hot and it's warm and you could smoke dope and air and people
still abroad as like a little house.
It's like a little house.
So you don't know how many times I swear to God I got an a gun onto it and you
know,
hi,
I'm Brian.
I you mind?
No,
no,
no.
Come on in.
And where you guys from?
Texas.
Oh,
nice.
Where are you from?
Jersey.
Uh,
what do you got to do with doctors and all of a sudden right before you're ready
to tip off,
they're like,
do you mind if we spoke a joint?
You're like,
come on.
Yeah,
we'll go to this bar.
Sometimes they give you a money that's still going on like that.
People listen.
It's like anything else on vacation they go to lose their fucking,
yeah,
and by the way,
it's going to make it feel better.
You know,
pops rooms,
the mushrooms and they go to pray skiing,
which you sit in the Jacuzzi and talk to people from five to seven.
I don't do that stuff even though he's really weird with educated.
He's,
no,
not me.
I'm just saying that's what they do.
Attack you.
You skied till four and it's called apt.
Pray skin.
I pray skin is where people go and they mingle and they'd talk shit and they sit
around you and you have a waitress who comes and brings you drink.
That's what I pray.
Scan is,
it's nothing bad.
I manage a Jacuzzi's or nothing,
but I like the skiing part.
You know,
I had a ski pass.
I worked that I'm not in a Jacuzzi.
Yeah,
I worked at Mr Video,
so he gave me a ski pass so the video store wouldn't open until 12 so I would
hit the slopes from nine to about 1130 go home,
eat the sandwich and go to work.
I had a three mountain slow,
I would never go to Ajax.
Ajax is like this dog that's not for Uncle Joey and you ate is like this with
lumps.
So you don't know what
is like this.
You'll like,
you know rock like you can't pass up.
Hey Jackson is like this.
Like this mother motherfucker's locks.
So people jump off the land type of shot.
No,
no,
no.
I went one time and I thought,
stop this right now.
Get me back.
I'm going down.
I ain't,
I ain't afraid to tell you Aspen Mountain bike and ski and Snow Mass.
I was the king because have you ever seen videos of those guys going down the
side of a mountain and an avalanche is chase and I'm like,
whoa.
That's a fucking crazy thing to do with your time.
Joe Rogan.
One time I was living in Aspen,
I was planning a jewelry heist.
There was a jewelry store at Snowmass village for I destroyed the Snowmass
village mall Christmas Eve.
If you can look up that paper,
look up,
uh,
Snowmass paper,
whatever it is,
1983 let,
why not?
It's 30 years ago.
It's going to be 30 fucking years because the statute of limitations run their
stuff.
Fuck.
The statute of limitations ran out of meat bitch.
Right?
So I was up Aspen Mountain one night and I,
and I got kicked out.
I just started opening up doors and the next day in the paper,
Christmas Day,
they had a thing that said snow mass more burglarized Christmas Eve.
So I was like,
there's a jewelry store.
I'm gonna rob up there.
They were up there for years.
I'm going to rob mother fuckers.
And at the
time I had the guy that I was an electrician.
I was a an apprentice electrician.
I bet.
Uh,
I was a residential Wyman and I also bent pipe for the fucking to the commercial
guys.
So I asked all your attrition is like,
Oh,
can you help me fucking get this wire?
And so he looked at me,
he goes,
we can do it.
You could cut the wire and the alarm will go off.
So the cops and they react to you.
So I had two weeks to go until I went back to Jersey and I went up there one
one,
then the blizzard.
It was a perfect man.
It's a fucking place.
It,
the cops can't get up to that to me.
I get up there and cut the fucking wire.
I break the glass and some may actually turn around and they see the cop cars,
Audi's.
They had not outbeat sobs.
Sobs.
Then I seen the lights,
but then they didn't have the sirens,
but they were down away from me.
They were down on what is just to show you how smart your brother,
Uncle Joey is.
They went down away from me.
So it's a blizzard.
They can't catch me.
So I put my hood on.
I didn't rob a jewelry store,
but they're coming.
So I start running,
I start running,
I fucking fall down the slope.
I cut around.
There was,
you know,
back ways to get into my house.
I lived on day 12 Creekside I climb into the apartment,
I take my clothes off and fucking,
I'm sitting there and within an hour I got a knock on the door
and I opened the door.
It's two shirts and they're like,
hi,
how are you doing that?
Have you seen anything suspicious?
And I'm like,
no,
not really.
No.
Like,
yeah,
somebody tried to rob the jewelry store.
Time me the fucking genius.
I walked in the snow and made a path right through my fucking door.
So the guy says to me,
you haven't been out all night.
And I'm like,
no,
I've been home all night watching TV.
And he's like,
who's boots are those?
And I looked down and you can see the snow falling off a melting,
right?
The heat.
And I'm like that my boots.
And they go,
so you haven't been out on?
I go,
no.
I had to go out to the car to get the fucking cassette out of the car.
Whatever.
He goes.
Well,
it's funny cause the path and that jewelry store leads right to that fucking
silly bitch.
They had me,
but they'd had no charges.
I met disappeared two weeks later.
So before the cops came knocking for me two weeks.
It takes that long to bring you to court.
They had nothing.
They had no fingerprints had.
They just had at the time there was about 20 fucking that they can't,
they hadn't mixed them in cutting the last time I'll get Barry Scheck.
They had no tools and nothing by the time that I remember for them to come in
your house,
unless you let them,
they have to have a warrant.
So they couldn't get you on just a footprint here to your house?
No,
I couldn't.
Cause I told him I went out to the car.
I couldn't mixed into somebody else.
What the fuck?
I get the fence list.
What the fuck dog.
Don't make me call Barry Shit.
You'll help clean with these footprints.
Were these lag time the footprints of snow had fallen over the silent night
still yet?
There was still over.
Oh no it doesn't.
It was depressing times for some reason.
We had a lot of people I themselves around Christmas song,
that song,
that's the fucking problem is,
is people that ice themselves around holidays is it just they don't feel loved
and they just get,
you know,
for some people the holidays,
a lot of pressure.
Somebody leaves somebody you're really love.
I mean there's a lot of that I wish in my life,
I got to love somebody that once they were gone I would die.
Like you hear like
a wife dies,
the husband dies all the time.
What happens all the time?
Cause you're probably with my grandparents,
we talked about it yesterday actually.
It's very sad,
but I never thought about,
you know,
Joe and all this shit.
But I went through,
I had never thought about icing myself.
I just always considered why Christmas though?
It seems like those like high expectations of love and then you measure yourself
up to you.
Yeah.
This is,
especially in Ohio,
you can't usually can't leave the house because of the weather area.
You're broke and you have to buy something for your girlfriend and your mom and
you're just like,
how am I going to do this?
So you're working more trying to pay,
make up enough money to pay for it.
Yeah.
President.
I remember when people would get Christmas jobs.
Yeah.
They would get extra jobs like high school,
like high school kids would get Christmas jobs.
I hate Christmas.
Yeah.
I can suppress a lot of pressure because I don't have a mother.
I don't give a fuck about gifts and all that shit.
I get depressed because you want her birth family members on my,
in fact,
my mother's birthday is ward in New York.
I've got to bring flowers for the fucking cemetery Friday morning.
Where's the cemetery?
Church.
We welcome.
And that's another thing,
especially when you live out here,
you can't see your family.
So you're sitting here by yourself and you don't have a girlfriend.
You're fucking sitting lean po,
I don't know,
like last two Christmases.
I bet.
Eight lean pockets,
you know,
instead of,
instead of fucking just go get some healthy food.
[inaudible].
It's like that even makes it worse.
Lean pockets.
Even if I'm alone on Christmas,
not fuck a rock.
I got weed,
I got pot cookies,
I go to Boston market and get a Turkey with the stuffing of the trimmings.
The solely things you could do,
it's like I've really been fucking depressed on holidays,
but to the extent that like I'm going to kill myself,
but I don't have a fucking family.
You know,
Christmas and your birthday is when you really think about your family.
You say,
you know,
before we came here tonight,
I did something.
I showed Joe and bread band,
my family in Cuba and I cried when I watched the video.
I never met these people go,
how would you feel?
Let's talk about if you will,
49 years old and you and your fucking cousins will come to hear the record,
an album,
Burbank.
And my uncle called me and he goes,
your cousins are coming from Cuba.
They want to meet you.
They've seen your movies and Cuba.
They watch youtube on Cuba.
So they wanted to meet me and they land at fucking lax.
And the driver says,
do you guys want to drive in La and see what La is about?
They go,
yeah,
and they go on Melrose and my name is on the wall.
At the Improv to do is show that night,
want to tell me what the chances are again,
tell me what the chances are again.
And they stop and they go in and thank God Rita was there.
It really goes,
I know who Joey D is,
is a Rita called me.
She goes,
I'm standing around your cousins right now.
How amazing is that?
How fucking I'm coming out of a fucking podcast with Dunkin is something and the
band is amazing.
Both of them.
And I fucking go to Hyundai and I meet them and one one side of the family's.
Why did it be him?
His sister is black and we go to canter's to eat while we're in Kansas.
Joe Rogan,
you know,
every morning I played music on Twitter and sometimes people give me shit,
you're a comedian.
I don't play the music for that.
I play the music because it's an energy.
I never knew it till I'm with my cousins.
They can't speak a word of English,
but they do the words to stay away to heaven.
They knew the words to 38 what's that smell,
Mr. Saturday night when you seen Cuban people save the fucking words.
They don't know what those words mean.
They told me they go,
let's sing.
They Sang Leonard Skinner had Saturday I special doll with the bees.
Don't know what Saturday night they don't know,
but it sounded like edit you beautiful.
They even did the guitars in the head.
Even that my cousin of black would even did the guitar.
Let's play a little bit of them.
There's a guy and a girl.
There's two.
We'll first put the voc cause God damn,
this is like some rage against the machine.
Be Wild and this [inaudible] I got high with him,
right.
How has the lyrics,
I don't understand what they're saying when how has the great the great lyrics.
It's just the revolution man.
And they sing about the revolution and be free.
And then I sat with them and they told me how they opened up for audio slave and
what they said fucking yes.
Nobody knows yes round about nobody.
[inaudible]
they sang that and that's what I had to go outside and smoke pot.
I was like,
so you guys just live off of American music and he at least fucking maggots put
it down and this and this to that.
There was everything.
Aubrey was at,
uh,
the black keys,
I guess he was in Austin.
The black keys are now and fucking,
he sent me a video from his iPhone.
They'll fucking places huge and it's packed and people are going fucking crazy
and the black keys are rocking out.
And I thought to myself,
I don't remember who it was.
Yeah,
I think it might've been Doug Benson that told us that he saw them at a place
like in San Diego years ago and the places like half full.
Yeah.
And you know why they sold out Madison Square Garden in 15 minutes?
You know why?
Because they're fucking Badass.
They're undeniable bad ass.
The only ones that are keeping it alive.
Right.
That's it.
Then the meal music.
That is real music.
There's no,
there's no horse shit,
not music,
man.
That's that.
And there's a reason why they just exploded with it.
All right,
so here's the joy ideas.
His cousin,
if you want to go on to youtube,
it's a the letter x and in a space Alfonzo,
and that's a l,
And this is the song called Vo and a c.
It's not ph.
It's not all phones with a penis.
Ff,
by the way.
Yes,
we are going to buy some sophisticated equipment that allows us
defeat this straight through your stream.
Eventually
government,
fucking communist government.
Let's do these mother fuckers [inaudible]
translate.
I'll plot line if I tell you
that I'm living out my fucking dream
culture of
all the fucking ankle.
I don't want things
that make her feel.
I don't know what the fuck
ass mother fucker.
Oh yeah.
Where do you stand in your [inaudible]?
They are fucking,
they opened up the audio slave.
They opened up the Ozo Motley.
Are they on iTunes?
They're on iTunes I think,
but the classic thing they did that fucking had me crying was when they told me
that Fidel's assistant went to them and said,
well,
we do the statue of John Lennon because Fidel had a vile of respect with John
when you know John Lennon was a half a cow be that guy used to beat the fuck out
of Yoko and his first wife.
He did.
Yeah.
He's a crazy motherfucker.
John Lennon.
John Lennon beat the fuck out of it was violent and shit.
He's crazy.
What did you read this a long time?
A lot of people know he would,
he would give up like Hendrix,
you know Jimi Hendrix used a beat up his girlfriend.
They led you dudes are fucking nuts,
bro.
That was one of the things in,
I guess it was are you experienced one of the books where I was reading,
because I had a conversation about whether or not Jimmy Hendrix did heroin.
You know when everybody always say there was acid or was heroin and what,
what was it,
and I've always attributed heroin,
did great music and some people have corrected me.
Then I found out that Jimmy Hendrix had tested,
uh,
who had been arrested for heroin in Toronto.
So it was like,
okay,
no,
he definitely did heroin,
but it apparently was after he had released all of his studio albums,
that's when he started doing heroin.
And,
um,
in this story where this guy was,
uh,
one of his bandmates was talking,
you know,
describing their life.
One of the things was about Jimmy beating up one of his girlfriends.
And I read and I was like,
Whoa,
man,
that's fucked up like that.
I didn't want to believe that.
I don't want to believe that Jimi Hendrix is beating up his fucking girlfriend,
man.
You know,
after the Beatles,
John Lennon was fucking that animal.
I mean,
he was a coal rider of fame by David Bowie,
which is a bang and fucking song.
He was the co writer,
belly of the jets,
and he put an imaginary,
you know,
has all those great fucking songs on it.
I mean,
that,
that imagine album was fucking deep with a deep,
uh,
you gotta be crazy fucking subway.
I mean the Motherfucka lived at the Dakota in the middle of New York City and
walked around without a body guard.
Wow,
that's incredible.
Now your cousin's sister's also has her own shit and other bad ass musician and
your family and her name is m.
A.
E m.
E.
Alfonzo,
a.
L F.
Like just in that,
if you thought that shit was bad ass,
then you have this,
which is just even crate.
Her voice is amazing.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
when they see me.
So the flavor just runs in your whole entire family.
That's the valve,
that side.
That's not the DS side.
The as is the rich from Cabo way cube where they would doctors,
the Valdez side is just too fucking overwhelming.
You know,
we sat a cancerous and they were telling me how would they see in me on the,
you know,
they love that Alex Jones thing.
Oh yeah.
People look up at subway a lot.
His job's Ezekial pilot.
They will fucking like,
they don't even know what I was saying,
but they knew I was going crazy.
But what they told me,
what they watched me on stage at the Improv and it killed me.
They said that you've never been around your family,
but you're then if you went back to Cuba,
I got the middle of the of the house and started telling stories.
You be about that.
It's like they still get together and they went and visited my sister that I'd
never met.
You know when I left Cuba I was three.
I never really remembered her and she's 10 years older than me.
They told her my sister that they were going to find me when they came to the
fucking states,
so they just got back to Cuba and I just emailed them yesterday and I'm probably
going to talk to my sister for the first time next week since my mother did die.
That bite [inaudible] 79 that's pretty crazy.
I'm talking crazy,
but they're all,
you see their parents,
they're my second cousins.
My first cousins,
their father is also a big time Cuban musician.
He's got a house the government does in my house.
She's got surfboards,
they give them fucking food,
you know,
he's fat.
And Mercury fill,
take good care of him,
you know?
But uh,
it's amazing seeing those people because I never do with my family.
It was about,
I had no fucking idea.
And they will even like talk.
We're all musicians.
How the fuck did you end up with this?
How the fuck did you do this?
But they all said,
you your grandfather,
your grandfather,
the same mother fucker even.
It's amazing.
Says you look like him,
your forehead,
your face,
and just your hustle.
The way he raised his kids.
I'm a valid,
so weird when you really see where you come from.
As much as I thought my mother was crazy.
They Valdez,
she stabbed the dude.
She had an alias and came to the states.
I didn't get social security alias.
Like red band has a stage name.
Yeah,
yeah man.
Fuck you.
And your stage name.
What's he on the bar in her aliens,
man.
She owned the business under her alias Sophia Cecilio.
So when the people come and go and Sophia,
we go,
I don't know.
No fucking Sophie.
And My mother would call Bowlby,
hit me in the attic up for you.
Get it together like you're supposed to know that.
I didn't know that.
Then I found out,
she's like,
when I'm at work,
you know I'm Sophia Cecilio.
That's really funny.
But when my mother died,
I couldn't collect social security because she had never worked on the real
fucking name.
So she worked on the alias and have all those businesses on their alias.
So something always comes back to bite you.
But it's really weird when you put together your fucking family tree.
Did you grow up being around your mom's bar?
All,
all every day.
Every day.
That's why I don't drink.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't drink because it was there for me.
So from the time I was,
from the time I was three to 12 I was at the bar.
Every day really isn't.
It's a way to have kids like learn alcohol around it have around.
So it's not some sacred thing that they can't get ahold of when I was having,
when they're young,
they're really telling him bottle of wines with the foot of fucking shit on it.
You know,
one of those want happy.
Okay.
Kathy,
when I was like for my mother told me a story that she was drinking thing and
after she went to bed I got up and drank half the bottle and she got up and
called the cops.
I was missing,
they couldn't find me like what the fuck is he go Quito.
And she called the cops and the cops found me in the closet with Bupa shit all
over me.
So after that dog,
there was no drinking from my ass.
You know what I'm saying?
That it was just no fucking drinking.
I puked in a cab once when I was 14 oh my pal Jimmy lawless.
We went to some party.
We're all listening to bad company drinking Jack Daniels.
We were like 14 drinking Jack Daniels.
Not having any clue as to how much I could drink.
Just completely experimenting,
hammered,
stumbling into things,
man,
boy,
but I was a mess back then.
I when I look back and I'm like so grateful that anybody was willing to be my
friend.
I look back when I was young,
you know?
Do you ever do that?
Like look back when you were young going,
God,
imagine if I had to be my friend when I was 14 and then you have that.
The reporter can't.
That guy we were talking about today,
the interview has,
he has his own podcast.
He's 13 and that kid's got his shit together.
He's a little band,
you know,
he's beautiful.
He's a prodigy.
Yeah,
that's his name.
That reporter kid toward a kid on Twitter and fucking kids.
Time for him.
Then when you open yourself up to a million dudes going to ask you to be on
their podcast,
hey,
I did because that kit's cool,
bro.
I do hit me up and I'll do the podcast.
You know,
if I have time,
I'll try to do it in day and I tried to help to out every week,
but like I have some people that contact me for Saturdays or Sundays.
I can't do it on Saturdays and Sundays during the fucking week,
you know?
Now people hit me up.
Can you do my pockets at nine o'clock at night?
You don't want me at the house at nine o'clock at night.
I'm smoked 80 fucking joints.
I'm burned the fuck out by nine o'clock.
Catch me early.
You know what I'm saying?
Cock.
And when are you at your best in the day?
6:00 AM 6:00 AM 6:00 AM is when I'm throwing heat giggling by myself.
Fucking habits.
When you're tweeting and all the best music.
Oh please.
I get so fucking fired up in the morning.
Stolen when I hit that first bond.
Lately I've been doing this in the morning just to keep it live.
Then this vapor fucks me up in the morning,
but it doesn't fuck me up in the afternoon.
So it's like,
that's a Tiva for me.
I always
smoke it early in the morning and then have to like to,
I've got to go back to the fucking heavy duty boy.
That was the last time you took a day off a week.
Do you ever do that two days before the surgery?
Yeah,
I'll try.
Oh two days before then I went off for a week.
I went off for a weekend.
Like December.
Yeah,
you have to,
you know this date.
Listen,
every day I wake up and I'm like,
today I'm not going to smoke,
but I wake up and my house is like a fucking opium den.
I got bongs,
I got the devices I got,
you know,
so you like I opened up my draw.
I've got a computer,
I find loose joints and containers and hash and I find I have so much shit at
the house.
So this day is like if I'm going to the doctor,
I don't want my blood pressure.
I won't smoke till two or three weeks.
I'd go on there just to give you a blood pressure fucking break.
You know,
there's days you got on the one on one and I've got to get high as soon as
possible.
You know,
like there's some days I got to get fucking high as possible,
bro.
You driving around the one on one or something,
you get so frustrated in traffic.
I never seen anybody get more frustrated.
Oh No,
no,
no.
It's not worth the aggravation in life.
This is my proposal.
Let's all get a series of houses together somewhere in Colorado.
Done.
Let's do it.
I'll buy it.
No,
you don't have to become the landlord.
no.
You don't have to buy a fucking around.
I buy a whole box is broken.
It's not going to fucking go,
so I'm going to have to deal with a reluctant witness,
listen to them and the victus Rogan.
At the end of the day,
she's going to have to realize that California is not going to get any better.
It's going to get more and more overpopulated.
Traffic is more and more she hasn't done well.
There's some complaints for sure.
There's,
first of all,
when you're dealing with this amount of people,
there's always going to deal with a massive amount of traffic and potential for
crime and you know,
Shit,
just shit along those lines.
You know,
car accidents,
drunk drivers,
texting,
people being fast and rude.
There's lake way more fast.
Cars is way more of that in a big city than there is in a small town.
Yeah.
But where you move vicious Rogan before you took her out of the loop,
you took around a civilization.
You can't do that.
See that's the,
yeah,
that's the problem.
[inaudible] married is it?
If it was just up to me,
I'd be living in like Batman either.
I drive up to the fucking cave and the little walls would open up and I'd go
inside and,
and I'd be somewhere.
If my house would just clearly reflected my first shore,
I'd be living in the mountains 100% I would have some crazy ass military style
Humvee that could just get through any kind of snow so I could get home no
matter what.
And that's what I would drive in the winter period.
And I would dealt with,
I would relish that and I would just deal with the fact that it's going to be
some times where you're stuck.
There's going to be,
some times we get snowed in,
there's going to be,
sometimes we're going to have to fucking shoot a shotgun off to get a bear off
your back porch.
You know
those,
you know that Galong as you know that going as long as you know that you live
like a doomsday prepper operators.
That shit.
I would watch that show.
What is it?
Doomsday preppers.
I'm discovering now.
You got to start watching my feet.
Yes you do.
About people that are get ready for the apocalypse needs current people that get
ready for fuck it.
Economic downfall of the country.
It's for people.
It's fucking crazy.
Joe Rogan,
they
build fluff.
You have to know you the IRS to see how the crazy world I've you really,
I know people that are doing that,
man.
I know people don't get house.
They have a thing outside their house and under water
ground rather bunker out in the desert out near Palm Springs.
There's like a place where you pay and you could buy like an underground
apartment,
like several layers deep under the ground,
like,
like floors deep
and just talking on food.
They're stocking on web.
I don't want to live if it gets to that,
this fucking guy had the nuclear bomb hits and 90% of us are dead.
I hope I'm in the 90.
[inaudible] let's,
let's see what comes with that fucking look.
I'll be in the weaves store with the bomblets and when I walk out,
everybody's dead except me.
I'm walking around like fucking I am legend.
Like,
well,
you know what's really fucked up that I've been trying to wrap my head around
lately?
I mean something that I've always known.
Can I take a little smoke break?
Go ahead.
What were you saying?
Um,
you know,
something I've been thinking about lately that I've been trying to wrap my head
around,
but it's really hard to,
you remember that,
um,
uh,
Crosby,
stills and Nash Song,
a Woodstock.
It goes,
we stop,
we go,
we are star dust.
We are golden.
We are billion year old carbon and we'd got to get ourselves back to the garden.
The,
you know,
I always like would listen to that and go,
wow,
what a cool lyric.
We are,
star us.
And then as I got older I actually like did a little bit of research on,
on the carbon based life forms and really like the,
the elements that are needed to create human beings actually come from stars.
Like we really are exploded stars.
Like how fucked is that that you take?
This is the most hilarious,
like I'm talking and you hear that.
Yeah.
It's like a Cheech and Chong album he took,
this starts from the skies.
We're talking about stars me,
but a human being,
I
literally cannot exist until a star explodes.
And then I believe that's probably the next cycle that human beings make.
The stars explode all over again.
That we,
we,
we get no fucking nutty.
Like we're doing with this Japanese thing where we have these fucking huge
nuclear power plants that can't be shut off or whether it's something else that
we're creating,
like the large Hadron collider or the next level shit,
anti matter experiments,
whatever.
Fucking crazy.
The thing that the half life video games style shit that they're actually
working on right now other than not telling us about.
I think that's probably the reason why human beings exist.
I think that's what we do by the word,
the end of the line before we blow the whole thing up and it starts all over
again and then it has to become stars and stars has to explode and that has to
create certain elements and then those elements have to combine and they have to
be water and next thing you know there's life and then that life has to evolve
and get more and more complex and figure more shut out until boom,
it blows things up all over debt.
Is that possible?
It seems like,
it seems like that really might be what it is.
It sounds ridiculous,
but it might be really what it is.
Star dust,
you need started to explode to make a person what the fuck sounds like a
hallmark card,
doesn't it?
Yes.
You need to start to explore to make you,
I mean,
it really is impossible to wrap your head around the amount of time involved in
all that.
It's impossible.
It's impossible to,
to put it into perspective where what you're saying is not just some abstract
noise,
you know,
especially me because of my limited amount of education and it comes to
astronomy and astrology and stars and I mean,
everything I've known about it is just from watching documentaries and reading
stuff and from books.
I'm never really formally studied it in college or anything along,
you know,
the,
the brightest astronomers and of the world or anything like that.
So when I talk about it,
it's so abstract.
Well,
you don't need to,
you can put two and two together and have your own,
uh,
take out what really happened that we all feel something different happen when
you know nobody fucking actually knows.
Nobody fucking knows.
Nobody fucking knows they can sit here.
Books are telescopes.
Nobody fucking knows what happened.
Where are we here?
We just have ideas of what was there before they found the fucking to,
to the fucking thing in Montana.
So obviously there was water in Montana 300,000 years ago.
That's all we know.
We can make a hypothesis from all we know,
but nobody fucking knows.
Nobody know.
If God created,
nobody knows these created by Adam's.
Nobody gives a fucking stock graded and they'll be willing to double block came
down from the fucking stars and made it with a chicken and a fucking sprinkle
things on the water.
How they say in Santa Rita every fucking week is different,
you know,
whether it's Adam's whatever.
It's very interesting and we each have our own fucking take on it,
you know?
And nobody's right and nobody's fucking wrong,
right or wrong.
Nobody's right.
Nobody's fucking impossible
to know.
I think it's really fascinating though.
It seems like what human,
the human race is,
is a race that woke up in the middle of something in the middle of an adventure.
That's what I feel like since we all have these temporary lives,
but yet we're all connected to the lives and to the actions of everyone that
came before us and everyone that's around us.
It really is like we're waking up in the middle of a journey like we are.
I mean that there's any analogy that I've used before that were on a star ship
and we woke up four minutes before we slam into a planet and they're like,
wait,
what's going on here?
What are we doing?
Where are we going?
We are riding the momentum of all these people that have existed before us,
but we didn't study what they study.
We didn't follow what they followed.
We didn't learn what went through their mind to get to their conclusions were
just riding on their innovation.
We're riding on their,
their,
their experiments and the results of them and their inventions,
their electricity,
their cars,
their airplanes.
We're riding on all their shit and we're just keeping it moving in the same
direction.
I kind of feel like that's a natural thing.
I got to feel like that's when I look at all the other life forms on earth and
everything destructive or constructive that they do from building dams,
to creating beehives,
whatever the fuck they do,
it's all natural.
And so why would we assume that what we're doing is not the same?
Why wouldn't we assume that the reason why we're so conflicted and weird is
because that's the proper mechanism that needs to be in place for people to move
forward in the direction that we're moving forward.
It'd be,
they'd be constantly chasing technology without any real clear sort of a
rational approach to using our resources and looking at the problems that we
have because we're like a bunch of little kids that have like shit all over
their house,
but instead we're,
we're outside working on the garden.
You know,
we're planting trees.
We're not cleaning up the shit that we piled up in the middle of the living room
and it keeps piling up every day and to the point where we can't even live in
our house anymore and we're concentrating on some shit that's not even ours.
Do you think you could ever live,
you probably couldn't,
but maybe in your,
maybe say like if you didn't have kids in the big families,
like do you think you could ever live in like one of those stream that trailers
by myself?
Fuck yeah.
Cause I was recently,
recently went to Joshua tree and one of those and I was thinking like really
this is all I really need and I can take my whole fucking house anywhere I want
and the new ones have like nice woods
floors and have some of expand out.
You know there's,
there's been um,
you know,
a lot of people that are moving towards minimalist house is really small houses.
Like there's a bunch of,
of all online that show like how certain people live and it's kind of
interesting,
you know like one guy figured out a way to have like this little tiny cooking
area and he pulls the bed out in the bed,
comes out of the wall and lives by himself and he has like some storage up in
top like toilet paper and things along those lines.
But it's a tiny,
tiny little house.
And a little kitchen dinette area and you know the ideas that like,
really,
why do we have to have this giant fucking footprint of House that we live in?
You know,
and yeah,
and these guys are getting paid.
Bitch,
if I want to live in a fucking cell,
I'm living a fucking sound like a monkey.
I'm going to live on a fault up bed.
Like I'm James Bond.
Like some fucking Puerto Rican that gets a check on the fifth.
Go Fuck your mother.
If you got paid,
you live in a fucking house.
I'm going to live in a Mike Rowe fucking out.
What?
A little kitchen to cook.
Like I got a black guy bagging me in the fucking ass.
I don't need that.
You spread out even me.
I'm no millionaire.
I've got a big fucking kitchen,
a micro house.
What are you fucking people talking about?
I just not thought of his dog.
You can't take me into those deep waters.
Like [inaudible] Rica fucking killed my brother right now.
A fucking house with a bed upside down.
Fuck that shit.
I'm trying to save vantage.
You.
Fuck you.
You get paid.
You fucking live like a normal person.
Go to Trump and say,
hey wig.
Moving to a fucking thing to say about it to see if you don't slap you.
If you don't have a Russian bitch slapping in the fucking mouth was fired.
The fuck are these people,
micro houses in the fucking desert.
You play it out to the world that like a doctor like a doctor.
You live your fucking life.
You're right.
Dooms Day.
I'm going to put a can of tomato soup under my span is the wait for the Martian
to come.
When it's over,
it's over.
You got one day when your Dick out and you take your fucking chances like a man.
I'm gonna live like I fucking old.
$20 to a bookmaker downstairs in my house.
Get the fuck out of my face.
I want to live in one.
This out there are struggling.
Brian's down.
Joey's not.
I think we have a real clear line.
See me feel like you're in one.
When you're in there,
it's,
it's pretty
until somebody farts and you're in full fucking speak Fisa and you're like,
I paid $10,000 so I can smell your asshole.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Cause everything's great in a small space.
They'll,
somebody blows a fucking floor.
You will walk into a bathroom at some of the Oh shit fucking bothers you.
Even if they're your mother,
you look at them like you dirty fucking Dicks,
a candle,
something.
Even if you,
you don't want to sell,
you don't want to live.
Nothing small.
Fuck that Shit Bro.
Especially,
I'm never home though.
You know,
like I worked so much I,
I'm never hide.
You always fucking call.
I'm home to sleep.
And here's a technical question.
When you light a fire,
when a match in a bathroom,
after someone took a shit,
does it burn up all the methane in the air or does just the smell of the mache
mask?
What am I smelling?
Not a science guy.
Covers candle just covers this.
Now is that all of this,
I can be completely wrong,
but that's what I always thought.
No,
I get good candles or air wick ones and I like to have them.
I like one when I go into this shit cause it's fucking Blab,
a backroom and a half.
I like how Joe Rogan loose.
If you don't have a bathroom and a half,
you're missing out on fucking life.
That's what I'm dealing with.
Have one big back room and that's where your girl goes and puts her makeup on
and you tell the bitch,
listen,
you see that little corner right there?
It's a toilet in three feet of fucking area.
That's my shit back.
Yeah.
That's why shit and let my balls out of the sink and I fucking pop pimples.
I might nut sack and I fucking whatever you're on the phone,
they got you jerk off material.
You know there's all these things that people are successful and they miss and
it's always bothered me.
Like if I was filthy rich,
I wouldn't get a car,
get a ritual and have motherfuckers drive me around.
That's [inaudible] can have a limo or you're going to fucking little trends
driving you around.
Yeah.
You sharpen a premiere with a ritual.
A ritual.
You show up in a premier with a ritual like what?
Bitch?
Everybody shows up when their limo,
you've got a little fucking guy that's sweating to death.
You come on,
they shit that you need that people don't talk about when you feel bad for that
dude,
I don't.
As long as I'm getting,
as long as he's getting paid.
If you weren't billions and you tell a guy looking at at night,
you're going to drive from fucking north Hollywood,
the San Diego.
He's going to be all around,
but they could tell you about if you are an MMA fighter,
that would be a great fucking training,
a great night of conditioning for your legs.
You can really get some good conditioning.
They still have dumb shit like that.
Like they have a people who will own that.
They still remember that business.
They started in Hollywood where if you didn't want to drive drunk,
somebody would pick you up on a motor scooter and they have all these.
Do you want to drive drunk?
Some of them pick you up at the school if you didn't want.
Like they have all these little fucking only weren't,
they try shit like that,
but that's what,
he's smart and they take you home and it's cheaper than a cab.
Is there things you miss out on?
Like if I was fucking filthy rich,
I have a big back room just for myself when I'm a day and have one of those
Japanese things where the water comes out,
washes your ass hole for you.
What would you have in your fucking back room?
That's success having shit that me having an iPhone that don't do dick for me.
You know?
And if you are one machine gun,
yeah,
an iPhone that turns into a machine,
that's fucking what I want.
You did this to him.
You know what happened that we found out how much weed it takes before Joey
snuffs in the Bryan and he picks up Brian's energy.
Yeah,
you're beyond that,
but I've never heard you go that deep into the crazy ball.
Oh,
please.
I went to the bottom of the bowl and you're just scraping the,
I'm telling you dog amount of broken pieces of pasta off the bottom.
I got my fucking tape.
Some of the crazy ball.
No,
but it's all the shit we do.
We don't focus on like to be the best part of me living as that little back of
my head.
That's my world and I hate fucking minutes.
That's my word of Japanese.
Don't we shitting in my toilet.
I'm one of those guys.
Don't shit my toy.
Don't piss up bucket strangle you.
That's what I'm going.
James Brown,
when he got arrested by the cops,
remember it was shooting at the cops high speed chase.
They blew out his tires because he came out with a shotgun.
Some dude was using his bathroom.
He went crazy.
Oh Bro.
That's some do use respect to do.
Took a shit and James Brown's draft,
somebody comes to the house and dumps a Douche in your bathroom,
like ate up the shoot that day that the shooting.
You know what comes out of tape ass?
That's tear gas.
You imagine the tape melting your fucking toilet with that way.
Fucking protein ass.
That's terrible.
I have,
I have one bathroom.
It's right next to my bedroom.
Anytime I have a new girl come over even or an ex girlfriend or girlfriend at
the time,
like you sitting there and she's trying to cover up the sound with the water and
the humming and whatever she's trying to do to make and you just hear like a
plop and you're just like,
ah.
It's the,
the,
the grossest thing ever.
And I think living with one bathroom is one of the worst things in the whole
entire,
I hate to,
I hate it.
I fucking I my elbow,
it's gross.
I well my own bathroom,
I got my little shit at my own toilet paper.
Magazines.
That's it.
I need to fucking move on.
Even when you touch a magazine,
reading it with their Shitty fucking hell,
like the shitty that's well touched.
Nothing.
I don't like shit in people's,
I don't like shooting an episode.
I had to shit bet on that flight next to you in Atlanta.
I held that motherfucker like a soldier.
You understand me?
Just cause I roll like that.
Nobody would shit in the bathroom.
That's no clash on a fucking bathroom on that floor to wall.
You gotta do what you gotta do is show the fuck not fun and keeping shit inside
my body.
I like to let it go.
Barest dog.
But you know what comes out of my ass if I draw of the white or to to rather to
to flush.
That's the problem.
Joey will leave these landlock shits on top of it because especially when you
were even bigger,
when you were bigger,
you couldn't sit on a toilet normally.
So you had to be like towards the end of the toilet.
So he would draw off on dry land.
I'd do it on purpose.
I like my balls off site.
Listen Bro,
listen,
I like you like your balls outside like an outside cause I'm like well your room
for error is so small.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't want my balls rubbing up against some of the other guys balls.
Then your wife or your girlfriend have to lick it.
It's everybody's water.
Oh,
coil.
I always hold my balls in my hand.
I protect them.
Oh my case.
The Nazis drop a bomb.
I got my fucking nuts in my hand,
but when I shit,
it just goes long.
I was telling him Thompson Google yesterday,
you ever take a shit?
You look at it,
you're like,
I could take it up the ass if I had to [inaudible] I just showed a 22 inch piece
of Shit my ass.
Oh,
it always dawns on you for a second.
It's [inaudible].
You're like,
what the fuck just came out of mine.
Some people clearly like things in there.
I got to go live on youtube coming out.
It
comes out of your Richardson's illegal.
You'd have to go to youporn 12 look at what comes out of your red.
Have you ever looked at your shit?
Like you look at it for a minute.
You're like,
you shake your head and then when you flush it and that shit breaks in half of
the full Patois,
your uracil because the shit is hitting the stick.
What's that piece of shit breaks in half?
It's like one of those fucking things that when you wave,
when the cops come like a Flint,
right?
When you break that one,
when that water hits that shit and it breaks in half,
that's what the essence of your asshole comes out.
You put the thing,
the toilet down,
they come back and hour later and pick it up.
He lived the bathroom.
Don't smell that last Patois of your asshole.
Those fumes and all those gases that was stuck in that fucking Milky Way.
If coming out feels good then,
but sex is 50% great.
Yeah,
it's probably,
it's probably 100% great fuck.
You can get over the fact that the guy's fucking in your asking grantees or the
new blonde.
You know when you,
when you do time and you're like in county jail,
you got to shit in front of everybody.
Yeah.
I'm an imagine and let me tell you something.
You Shit,
the first thing they say to you like gangsters,
look,
you can go flush that mother fucker dog,
but some water that mother fucker,
but you can't even leave the shit in there for a minute.
You gotta take a shit and flush it because brothers or start yelling,
put some water in that.
I'll make a tweet about something that I think is crazy.
Some new scientific find some giant 30 foot bird that was like some dinosaur
looking thing that ran around on two legs.
Didn't fly and you'll get like a couple of responses.
But just last night I,
I tweeted that my piss smells like tuna fish because it did.
Oddly I was like tuna fish with celery.
I don't know what it was to fun,
healthy niche,
but it smelled a lot of the tuna fish sandwich.
I got more retweets and more,
more responses.
Today you might have a yeast infection.
Well that'd be crazy.
No,
it doesn't smell that much.
It's a slight essence.
How much?
A small little like,
yeah,
I'm like fucking pussy.
If you rub it sometime you were rubbing a helmet in the middle of the night.
And I was like,
if the helmet and you'll like,
it smells like rotten fucking pussy.
Like all the pussy you got in the eighties and nineties cumulates kill me.
He leaves.
I don't want this shit.
What I,
one time I had some horrible farts and I was like,
my farts smell like war or something like that.
I put that up on Twitter and do is just kept.
It became a Hashtag.
It was pound sign,
my farts smell like,
and it was the most response of anything I've ever put up onto it.
I mean it was like for hours and hours it was just,
I get my farts smell like in a Hashtag I came up like 10 of them.
People love the craziest shit.
That's real you.
It's fucking real,
man.
We all look at that.
Great.
It's so funny how willing we are to delve into silliness.
You know Bro,
I sit there at night with a sleep apnea mask because I'm a fat fuck.
I got sleep apnea.
The sleep apnea mass has a tiny,
tiny,
tiny little exhaust hole in the front,
tiny like sometimes the cats will come in front of it so the air blows on them
and they like it and stuff.
My goal at night is to Fart,
to smell that far come into that.
If I could smell that far to that tiny hole.
I know my job.
I'll fucking soldier.
I'm a fucking soldier.
You understand me?
You don't know how many times I'll float like a two in the morning and our move
and I'll smell it and I'll giggle.
Do you take the mask off and not get it?
He says,
well no,
no,
no.
Sometime let's,
it's tremendous when you cup your ass and put it to your face like
fifth grade shit.
When you come,
you're a grown man that she never goes away,
does it?
No,
no.
It goes,
you don't know by people stopped playing is not because playing isn't fun.
It's cause you got too many fucking responsibilities.
You got no time to play.
That's not good.
Yeah.
Well it's also because you feel like you have to cause you have to be,
man.
I man,
I'm so tired of him.
I mean I've,
I've seen so many people,
like I've been like one of the things that I get criticized loans,
like you dress like a high school kid who you're I going to Bruce Lee t shirt
on.
Like,
what am I,
how am I supposed to supposed,
did he give a fuck how a person dresses?
I mean,
unless someone is like going way.
I look right today I have just a pair of shorts on just normal GI Joe Schwartz.
I've got some Cammo see that shit.
Nothing spectacular.
But this is just what I wear.
I mean it's,
it's,
there's nothing outrageous about it.
It's not like I'm wearing skinny leather pants and,
but people are always looking to find some standard,
you know,
they're always looking to find some like you're not supposed to act like this.
You're not supposed to dress like this.
You don't supposed to be like this.
Why don't you grow up Joe Diaz?
What are you doing?
You Smoking Weed every day?
Yeah.
That's great.
What kind of a message you sent in the chip?
The kids in the world.
Huh?
I don't want to grow up.
If this means that growing up,
this goes away.
I don't want to do it.
Probyn only child.
I've got a paraded in my head when I put,
when I smoke dope,
it's like giving him the engine.
I just enhance myself.
You know what I'm saying?
When you write at night,
you ever get to the zone where you actually a giggling like a four year?
Many times that's what success is.
Making yourself giggle like that as a comedian sometimes if you can't do that
love.
Look,
I was about to tell you something before Brian,
one of the silliest nights me and this man had,
he's going to remember,
he came to the comedy store at seven o'clock.
This was way before fear factor.
We were giggling and the Italian kid went up on stage and me and you were
sitting in our chairs just watching people do three minutes and some guy came on
stage and he goes,
how you doing?
I'm from a big Italian family.
There's a picture of the porch.
Remember you went,
do you remember that?
How much are you when I die?
And I'm like,
what?
I'm like,
That wasn't funny.
Yes,
it fucking was.
You know,
it's a picture like when Italians come out of court and people think of pig
genetics are the hands of [inaudible].
This is a picture of mine who's an PR and we were sitting back there,
hi.
You know what?
You're freed up waiting and watching three minutes of everybody and all of a
sudden this kid comes up and he goes,
I'm the town isn't impersonation that my family portrait.
I haven't been fucking lost.
Yeah,
we were just being silly.
That's,
I love that shit.
I love,
you know,
uh,
what's the Indian,
ah,
my name is,
uh,
you know the,
the old Indian from Michigan that used to be at the store sweetheart of a guy.
Charlie.
Charlie Hill.
Yes.
How you doing?
My name is Charlie Hill.
My original name was mountain,
but I got it shortened.
Come on,
come on.
You know what I'm saying?
That's,
that's the kind of joke that you're walking by and you're like,
what did he just say?
What is that stupidity that came out of his mind?
How are you doing?
I'm a retired.
It's everything Brian says.
I'm originally from all day to New York.
We had to leave because we had a small real estate problem.
Then.
It's so subtle.
It's so stupid.
I liked that shit is oh,
Neda,
where Manhattan was,
is that what it is?
I think it's up north if I'm correct or native native New York.
I don't know.
He was probably on native tribe.
Often has to do with it.
I know there's an old native New York by New York is the most ridiculous,
most ridiculous example of stuffing a bunch of people into a small area.
Like they apparently they're going,
oh,
they're trying to figure out how to finance more bridges and tunnels to get
people back and forth from New York to New Jersey and the governor Christie
wants the New York people that pay and you know,
I don't know,
there's some discrepancy,
but I was thinking about it.
I'm like,
what a crazy spot where there's like how many people,
how many millions live in New York City?
Look it up.
Especially like the Bronx and all the boroughs.
Brooklyn is the number that most people don't even know that.
You know,
there's the number four largest city in the country was 20 years ago.
The problem with Brooklyn is you have a melting pot of New York City.
You asking Siri,
you,
you've covered the problem with Brooklyn.
It's the fourth largest city in the country and it's a melting pot.
Now what people don't understand is that you have a city,
like you have the Bronx,
Brooklyn was,
is there 8.17 5 million while and you've got five barrows.
Correct.
You've got let's name real quick so I don't fuck up Staten Island,
Staten Island,
Long Island,
Long Island.
The Bronx,
Brooklyn,
Queens,
Staten Island and Manhattan.
Five barrels.
Not to mention across a bridge you got New Jersey.
Not to mention you've got long island and Connecticut.
A lot of people driving in every day from climate people that you know how many
people that fucking is congested like that and how many people would drive in
from like Greenwich and places like that didn't don't like Glenn back and all
those guys they drive in everyday.
How long has that drives that?
An hour,
hour drive back and forth,
45 minutes.
A lot of them take car services to make life a lot easier,
but that's still creates a lot more.
But you only going back at one person in the fucking car,
but at least he could read and shit when you're in the car,
if you have a car service from you for the other angle,
but uh,
it's just amazing.
You gotta be able to afford a car service lead knuckleheads.
Do you have in those five barrows,
car services?
Fucking expensive.
Now thinking about,
thinking about pain of her car service every day,
how many people could do that fucking day?
Six days a week.
Really grind on you.
You.
After a while you'd be like,
you know,
why am I paying so much money?
This,
I could go out to eat at a nice restaurant every day,
which you probably don't have a car,
right?
So you're not paying the insurance,
which is high in that area.
Why would you not have a car and live in Connecticut?
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Let's say you from a family and your wife has a car,
right?
You have one car,
you sold your car and you have a car service.
First of all,
if it's a write off into New York,
the back and maybe company you work for picks up half the task.
Very few people like especially like how about living in New York,
like trying to rock and like that where you,
you're just not going to have a car.
If you're a young guy and you're living in New York,
you're just happen.
Cab to cab everywhere.
Getting on the subway.
That's one of the few cities,
very few cities where you can live with no car.
I have a friend that at 48 just gave up his car.
He goes up to three years.
I realized,
what am I doing?
I'm paying this.
I'm leasing.
I just get a rental.
If he wants to go.
Some wants to go someplace and I just get a rental,
which is now that that is smart.
It just makes fucking sense.
I wonder what the percentage of people in New York City that don't have cars or,
I bet it's giant.
Well,
if you're young,
let's pretend you're under 30 you're insurance starts at like 2000 a year to
2,400 $2,400 a year.
Insurance means you're paying an extra $200 a month on top of your car payment,
which if you lease or whatever,
for 600 you know,
gas is $4 just to have a car and the parking spot,
fucking dollars.
Plus,
you know,
people someday get,
when we were talking about,
uh,
values,
you know,
you buy a car.
Last night a car Cadillac dealer came to the show,
just a kid who was parents on the Cadillac dealer.
We,
we're talking about the car.
You like the $75,000 car.
And he goes to a lot of people who are doing,
is that buying the lease returns because it naturally off 25,000 off the price,
or you still get the same quad with 5,000 that Cadillac,
the Cadillac cts,
cts,
it's supposed to be a fucking animal.
Now they have a place in Orange County that's let's fix them and make them even
faster.
That's correct.
You don't need to say.
Yeah,
right,
right.
The cts visa of something like 550 plus horsepower,
those are ridiculous cars.
So you look at all of these things as an American,
you and the,
and eventually times again,
rough and you look and you go,
what do I need and what can I live with that?
I mean,
I'm in this house,
John airstream trailer.
How Lazy Are we?
I mean,
all right,
but looking at la,
they have a great train center.
You know,
nobody wants to take that.
Nobody wants to take it,
but bro,
you don't have to deal with that shit.
You could take the train by my house,
Hollywood and vine and be downtown for a late game and staples and come back for
a concert.
It's really fun.
It's not New York,
it's not 20 people.
I think the real issue though is also you're going to have to deal with all the
other people that are on that train.
And in California,
that's a God damn mixed bag.
And we're not used to interacting with each other like we are in New York,
but it's only like,
what,
five minutes,
five minutes been a,
but in New York,
when,
you know,
everybody goes out everywhere.
Like if you're walking around in New York,
everybody is interacting with everybody.
That's not happening in La.
One of the reasons why there's a lot of racism and a lot of weirdness in their
lanes that we don't interact with,
with people of all sorts of different nationalities and all sorts of different,
you know,
a household incomes.
We don't,
they don't like really coexist in one big melting pot the way New York is.
New York,
like you'll see the subways and there's a dude with a fucking $5,000 suit next
to like a homeless guy and this a homeless guy sitting on a train and next to
the homeless guy.
There's a young kid with his Walkman and everybody's just interacting together.
You know,
they avoid the homeless guy,
ethanol possible,
but in nobody's riding anywhere with no homeless people.
You know,
this is not happening very often.
You're not always around them.
In New York,
you're always around them.
In New York you're always around all sorts of getting young black kids,
young Chinese kids.
There's a bunch of different people interacting with each other.
Whereas in La everybody's in their little box,
the little metal box and little rubber tires and it's rolling around their real
self contained environment while they give people the finger and text each
other,
you know,
so it's that that lack of person to person interaction is one of the problems
with the,
the the way people act in La,
the one of the,
the number one problems with the way people act in La is that they,
they're not interacting with people like all kinds of different people,
a real melting pot.
They get in their own niche and they stick there and they stay and they,
they,
they surround themselves with like minded folks like we do.
You know,
it's so weird.
I scares the shit out of me.
Like I always read about Tara,
things lost in New York because I got a tap.
Everybody's fucking phone in New York.
Everybody's phone is tapped in New York because that's the only way they're
going to find out about these types of things and it's so real.
How is that possible though?
Someone listening to every call for years to stop the for you know,
for the same things for years before nine 11 if you said certain words,
something would pay.
Like if you said bomb or eight ball fold it would be I t now they have more,
uh,
you know,
a fucking amazing ways to tape you,
but we really baffles me.
Joe Rogan and you've seen it.
We're going to see it next week.
What if,
I mean you have to really,
what if there's a disaster in New York at five o'clock?
Yeah.
It would be something that I can't even wrap my head around,
but you can't wrap your head around the stars and all that shit.
That's great.
I couldn't wrap my head around.
If there's another nine,
11 and P and it's five in the afternoon.
I was there in [inaudible] 94 when the guys from Jersey City,
the world could blow up the World Trade Center,
the photos.
And I know what that was like.
I don't know.
I was pissed because they knocked one of its hours down.
I couldn't get no coke.
So you couldn't pay to nobody because they knocked the towers down.
That thing went down.
There was no communication.
You mean the power?
The power down.
Well they not Obama,
but it didn't,
I'm sorry.
They had a cell phone tower was on top of the World Trade Center or something.
But that afternoon,
if something happens,
so all the phone systems and New York are fucked up.
In those days it was pages.
It was 94 pages.
Wall fucked up.
People weren't getting pages.
I drove a limo.
So I remember that.
That was the big thing.
But you think about what a fucking four 30 in the afternoon,
something that happened,
those people underground in the subway.
I think about the people here with the subway.
You know,
cause I take the fucking thing for language.
If you ever want Pastrami up,
they'd get him on the bucket of Lang is downtown on Alvarado.
That's like the worst neighborhood in the world.
But it's the best pastrami sandwich.
We'll have in California got the second best thinking and I take the fucking and
I take the,
and I had been the langurs and can't fuck with cameras.
No flux with candidates.
I went this last week,
the people that work,
listen,
waitresses that worked at Canada's at night work at language and the date time
they'll tell you,
so I'll drop that shit.
[inaudible] is
[inaudible] bed is the bread is crusty.
I went to campus last week,
go to the next day I shit.
And it smells so rotten.
Pastrami was old and read.
Once it comes to your ass hole,
that's how fucking lag is at 12 o'clock and you see the boat bumpers and pull up
that take out window.
That juvenile.
Okay.
We should do,
we should.
We should do a a a taste.
Oh please.
I'll tell you.
I bet bars in the valley's very good too.
But the problem with modern is they don't have the bread.
Lang has got booked.
Is gives you crispy.
That's the same for astronomy I had at my wedding.
Don't tell me that.
That's the first thing that bottom went.
So lag.
Isn't this town somewhere.
What street is lingers on in magazines,
on Alvarado and across from that park out,
whatever.
Parkland merch park or whatever.
I walked in there one time.
The first person that came up to me said,
you want to buy a passport and ID.
That's how real that area is.
It's a Jew Deli from 1940 at the area.
Grew up,
it didn't and they stayed there.
I know the daughter,
I know the father and I know what they fucking served and I know the mother
fuckers that go in there.
That's the old school fuck can is is nasty.
It's filthy.
Look,
I'm telling you,
this is your brother Candace is good years ago yet,
Bro.
You go to language and you get that motherfucker.
This guy don't know he's going to eat.
I'm so shocked at how aggressive,
listen,
315 pounds.
I'm from fucking mother fucking New York and nobody in this room going to stop
me in my mother fucking bus draw cats.
Nobody.
Can we go?
Can me hear me?
The cats is the best in the world is very good,
but I've been to other players.
Listen.
The good thing about New York cats is for tourists and wait and let's get out of
the way.
Catch is good,
but it's for tourists.
It's like this APP book place.
We'll all these dumb fuck come on.
Calories to eat.
I know there,
but it's for tourists.
It's for tourists.
I know,
I know.
I'm taking it to a fucking,
I'll take it to the lance he street and I'm getting you Pastrami.
That just as good.
I'm telling you this.
The truth,
that's a fucking tourist spot.
Now I'm telling you,
this is your brother.
I grew up in New York.
You can go up on 30 years.
I grew up in New York when New York was New York.
Ain't no mother fucker to come and tell me no mother fucking had been the rails.
I've been to that fucking place though.
You walk over the bridge for a steak.
That's one of the best they plays in the countries,
but all but strong and this is why the fuck he top pocket Radians fucking head.
This guy,
he's trying to pull that sleeve.
No fucking food.
You know he knows food.
I mean you don't know.
I love him to death.
[inaudible]
Bitch,
you sent me to that nasty place on unless shrank the Shim that pizza joint with
the old Spaghetti Tom Loves.
That's terrible.
No,
you to set up.
Gordon says God listens anything they Tony's.
Tony's needs to shut the fuck.
Like rest in peace and love.
Respect Tony Little Tony says you get the stuffed pizza pizza when the regular
pizza blows.
Now because I'm telling you that regular pizza,
it's a completely different story.
They know stuff.
Pizza,
I won't adopt.
Yeah,
that's some ridiculous shit.
I won't go to anything named Tony's at ever snow for Greasy Tony Crazy.
Tony is the only Tony as far I'm concerned.
Greaser Tony's
gone respect.
I love that question.
Died recipes.
Creasy Tony Crazy.
Tony from Tempe,
Arizona.
Not Boat people.
People via New Jersey's they've gone and done these shows on the discovery
channel.
They opened you up to these restaurants.
But now the first thing when people come from Tennessee as they want to go to
Katz's,
so they kind of fell off a little bit.
I want to catch two years ago.
It was good,
but I don't need that much meat on my fucking sound.
Would you go see?
I just need a little Pastrami to get my disagreement.
I do.
I make sure I eat even spot if I'm eating at Katz's.
I tried to do it on a squat day.
I try to do squats the day I eat it,
so I have a deep desire for flesh.
When I do squats and your body is depleted.
That's great.
I love the hats of policing for taking this shit.
Oh,
I,
I know.
I know how to handle that,
Joe.
It's called Salads.
No,
I know.
Everybody fucking knows.
You've got to try this.
A Kale shake that I'm doing.
I know that you don't get too much into that crazy shit,
but it's easy.
It's easy to drink.
I got the fucking book.
I don't like that menu.
I love Bob Bocce.
I try falling.
I don't like what all and Kale.
I don't eat that shit in Kale.
Kale does not taste good on its own if you just eat it.
I like it.
Had a salad though.
I've had an a salad with like some lemon juice on and stuff,
but the way you drink it in a shake,
it tastes good because it's got a pair and the pair,
the pair keep,
I put garlic in it too.
I put four cloves of garlic raw garlic,
so I'm meeting with all the super,
it makes me feel really good show.
Hey Rob Garlick everyday but this Kale,
celery,
raw garlic,
ginger,
raw ginger,
like a big hunk of it.
It's easy to drink and it's like super healthy and your shit comes out like it's
on a water slide Sean.
Oh that's why my shit comes out anyway.
Nice and smooth.
I don't like,
I don't have no residue on my asshole dog.
My am I eat like nine fucking apple before I go to bed.
I make sure before I shave in the morning,
I don't like that struggle.
I sit down,
I got a call to the eight on that toilet and by five two I'm done.
Wiped fucking second wife.
You don't eat apples,
you've got a second and wipe your ass all fucking day.
I gotta pull over on the fucking,
not a friend of mine had a real good point.
He was talking about dogs.
He goes,
if you're seeing these dogs,
take your shit.
I agree.
Yeah.
He goes,
how long does it take?
I go,
it doesn't take long at all.
He goes,
well,
how long does it take for you to take your shit?
And I'm like,
a lot longer than that.
And he goes,
yeah,
that's not good.
He goes,
if you're healthy,
you should be taking a shit.
Just like a dog.
You Open your asshole.
Most of it comes out in the first barrage and then maybe there's a couple of
Plop,
plop plops at the end where it's sticking to the walls and done.
I don't know,
sitting,
taking a shit and that shit takes three hours on your ass.
That shit about people doing good for your asshole.
I've never run this.
If you get to nine,
I don't sit down until that ass what was ready to blow once I smell that last
fucking shit,
fuck.
That comes out of your belly button.
That belly back the Muffler and comes out of your fucking belly button.
You sit down and get that ass on one sheet and then you do that fucking ass
right to the other man.
That asshole opens up like fucking one of those boy and chicks and that shit
comes out like soft serve.
That's the way it should be.
I got to find out what the weed was that we smoke today cause that shit was
ridiculous.
Was that shit ridiculous then is a whack you?
Huh?
How many,
how many hits did you have?
Like 19 how many hits did you have for I think,
I don't know that,
that we cracked me,
man.
I,
I was on delay for the first hour.
We were talking like I was talking and I was,
I was cognizant of what I was saying,
but I was like hearing an echo.
I was like,
whoa.
We definitely went too deep here.
I think you smoked smells from no home p off from this new fucking place.
I found 15 gram and they have the fucking,
we'd tested@statlabs.com station.
There's a weed testing lab.
Oh yet,
fuck you.
Oh yeah.
It's all over at a bull's get tested there.
That's of when you sit down on the car.
They'll tell you it's 21% this a NLC CPR.
I think it's 28% it's the highest.
What's Matt's Oji Kush is the highest 31 but I haven't been done in about three
months or four months,
so I don't know.
Everybody changed.
Did you say 34 at one 31 32 it was pretty,
I had the paperwork.
He goes magazine,
but now they had a new company that's doing this for the valley.
These guys are trying to stay decent so when the cops come,
Obama comes,
they're going to try to show them that what they're doing.
So these guys have a car.
When you go get the weed now there's a card.
It's signed with a phone number if you want to call the labs,
and it has a percentage of weed
getting it also has it for the edibles it seems.
Oh,
sorry.
It seems that Obama's trying to do is they're trying to cut off the big scale
operations.
They're just,
I think you're a little shiny gold and people that are fucking it up and they do
a shit.
Okay.
Ain't doing nothing.
They ain't doing nothing.
I buy weed at the same fucking place for the last four fucking years.
People don't do it or not.
There was a big papers I know,
but the places that are selling illegal,
if you go to a decent place,
I haven't gone to the same place for two fucking yeah,
let me shut up there and that shot nothing.
These are all rumors.
So all stories is there full.
She has bad places that there are knocking down.
Ain't shit.
Look a dog fucking fail.
There's this looked like they're slow on this shit up.
Joe Rogan does this look like,
Oh Bob is slow and privates.
I stopped.
He ain't doing dick.
People stopped with me.
What?
You're dumb shit.
Obama was going to close the stores in 30 days.
You ain't doing shit because you see occupy La and occupies failed.
You fucking lock up these weeds.
Store now's and see the problem.
These mother are going to have downtown.
This'll be real.
You got people,
you got half a million people were drug licenses now close to a million Butte
ticket slowing down when they're making a fucking pen that has hash oil and it
that 30% yeah,
like really shutting him down.
Oh Wow.
Let's panics.
You stupid mother fuckers.
Don't you understand that money supersizes everything you dumb mother fuckers
know they're going to sit there and Washington and say,
Nah,
let those fucking hippies out there grow wheat.
Fuck you.
Then making billions.
It's keeping this stayed alive.
It's keeping the state alive.
These are a bunch of losers run in this date.
They closing Derek,
so for all you idiots at Twente me every time an article comes out that close on
one store a week and and the reason why
they closed closing this because they're out there basically Pelham the weeding,
giving it away.
Nobody else.
They did that at Oaksterdam.
I think it also down there and teaching people how to grow with the program.
There's a bunch of,
you know what to happens is Oaksterdam got a bunch of white kids that got big
fucking mouth shut your fucking mouth.
That's at the prom is shut your fucking mouth.
Everybody wants to be a hippie and a deadhead.
Shut your fucking mouth.
Okay.
Stop with the butane and everything.
This is we.
So there's this look like Obama's slows shit down.
I take a cap off and fucking hit it.
Does this look like it?
You stupid mother fuckers.
They shutting duck down.
It's keeping the lights on in this state.
It's not doing anything.
So forget that there's no war on drugs.
The war on drugs was 30 years ago and and they are shipping in what?
19 metric tons of cocaine by the year into this country.
So what war on drugs are you people talking about?
I heard something very interesting last week.
I listened to the Graham and God podcast when he was on him and he talked about
that with locking people up for raising our consciousness that the country is
locking people.
What's he talking about?
Yeah.
We're locking up drug dealers.
No.
Okay.
I'm just smoking dope for 30 fucking years.
I never got popped.
It's Bullshit Joe.
People get caught that a user.
What do they do to you?
Especially if you're,
if you're using like acid or something along those lines.
How long were you in jail for it?
I don't know.
I live for acid.
They don't.
When was the last time you read about an acid?
Know there was a big bus recently at a college where kids were selling it.
They sold like a quarter million dollars where the ads,
that's who makes the acid is the college towns.
If it wasn't for college kids,
we wouldn't have those drugs.
Still.
It would just be blowing heroin fucking alive.
But you don't read about shit.
But it won't kill me.
When I was,
he made a lot of great points.
He made a lot of great points in his,
isn't his thing,
but I was like,
what is he talking about?
We gotta put drug V,
we have laws and we have to put drug dealers in jail.
They put me in jail.
I didn't go cold.
I get caught for kidnapping,
but it all started by raising my consciousness.
You know,
some consciousness you have to raise.
I was telling these guys at the Ice House last night,
I did heroin three times in 2007 before I quit to him blow it.
I didn't do blow that whole summer and here I was thinking that the helm cured
my blow.
Like I was ready to call the doctor drew and go,
you're a dumb cunt.
Okay,
no one in the ties and white kids.
And I just did three $7 bags of heroin.
I thought,
hello.
I'm sorry,
what happened?
I haven't touched,
I haven't punched blow the whole summer.
It raised my consciousness red band to the level that I didn't snort coke.
You follow me?
I mean it was still bad.
Can you imagine?
You've got to quit coke by doing heroin,
but it raised my,
anything that raises your conscious,
I'll let you know something is bad.
Like that whole summer I kept going,
man,
thank God I did the heroin.
It let me feel how bad the cocaine is.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
but Joe,
I'm a cure it.
I never did it again.
So it raised my consciousness.
Nobody put me in jail.
I didn't understand what he was tapping.
I understand somebody,
there's something wrong.
You get caught selling drugs.
But I really never met nobody who got thrown in jail because he got pulled over.
So we'll you're saying is that he's making it,
he's exaggerating.
People that are gone to jail.
The dealers,
not the user name me one guy that's in jail for doing drugs or find them online.
Well,
there was a kid that got arrested recently in,
um,
in Texas and he had his medical marijuana on him.
It was just his,
and he's going to try right now,
they're taking him to trial and he faces a possible certain amount of years.
I forget what the exact number is,
but they're going to put him in jail.
They want to put him in jail to make an example of the fact that you can't have
medical marijuana and take it with you to Texas and think that your state's
laws.
Oh,
from Carolina,
Texas.
Yes.
So I think it's a,
it's a precedent setting law.
So in that kid's case,
it's,
I mean,
it wraps around the idea of the laws.
You know,
the,
the medical marijuana laws,
whether or not they're even legitimate,
you know,
there are states that won't even consider it.
They don't think it's legitimate.
That's why I'll stay here for now.
Yeah,
it's so,
it's so archaic.
It's so archaic to this.
I mean,
there's a goddamn mountain of information now and the information can tell you
that it's relatively harmless and then you compare it to all the things that are
legal.
No one should ever get hassled for it.
No one should ever get pulled over for it.
No one should ever get arrested for,
no one should ever get fined for it.
It is relatively innocuous to our society and our children be able to use it.
No,
they shouldn't.
But guess what?
They shouldn't be able to use alcohol.
They shouldn't be able to use heroin.
They shouldn't be able to use any conscious altering thing before they get their
fucking shit together.
I agree with this 2013 and what you mean to tell me is that somebody would get
arrested for smoking pot.
They still can turn the hose and twist the 2012 2000 and Turkey and I'm fucking
spilled and people are still getting arrested.
How sad is that?
It's all the problems that we really have in this country.
You're going to come and fucking handcuff me for fucking having a quarter
rounds.
What is going on in Florida?
I mean that thing in Florida that we talked about where the kid was arrested by
his girlfriend,
he thought he was,
he thought he was in love with some chick.
Turns out she was an undercover cop.
She went to high school at 25 year old woman,
went to high school and pretended to be friends with kids.
Yeah,
but there's gotta be a,
by the way,
that we're going to get,
something's got to overturn that.
A good attorney.
Oh yeah.
They're,
they're going to overturn with a tiny would overturn.
I saw about the fact that this kid has to go to court and that anybody would
raced resources going after a 15 year old kid,
but we didn't even sell her the weed.
The kid didn't even sell it to where he got it to her for free.
She kept asking him about weed.
He didn't even smoke weed.
The kid was an honor roll student and let me tell you something and I'm going to
tell you [inaudible] you can to call it.
I've been involved in drugs for 30 fucking years at all levels and if you can't
look at somebody and put a cop uniform on them and though there were fucking
have the cup of cop,
you shouldn't be doing drugs because when you smoke a joint you should be a
light to see this shit.
I know when I smell a cop,
I smell a 15 year old kid with a boner.
You think should be able to tell a 25 year old hot chicks I was around.
Buck Hill is managing.
That would even be something that someone would consider instead of doing.
That's why I don't,
I'm not sweating.
I would
sue.
I've not only overturned that,
but I would sue that fucking bitch and that police department and that bump
jurisdiction for everything.
They got that fucking townhouse.
We'll call it be called Joe.
We'd be is fucked in memorial park down as
and with that,
ladies and gentlemen,
let's pull this fucking boat into the beach and docket.
Ladies and gentlemen,
once again,
Joey DSS provided hours of free entertainment.
Let us stop.
Pause.
You're a goddamn classic.
Come see us.
Are you going to do the Ice House Friday?
No.
What are you doing Friday?
I got some fucking Gig.
I'm gonna open up a call to gang or some shit.
Where don and I told you they have that disco series,
Bro.
So somebody,
where is it?
How do we get there?
How does people,
how do people buy tickets?
How they find out about when you bought,
I just got the Gig.
It'll be on your Twitter,
right?
Yeah,
but not bad flavor.
Is this Twitter and late night?
Saturday night have an arch for joke at the end bar.
10 o'clock tickets on Brown paper.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Loud paper tickets.
Go on there.
Me and Brian are going to Columbus tickets,
almost sold on Columbus tickets are almost sold out in Pittsburgh and we're
halfway in fucking three quarters in Cleveland.
He's 17,
18,
19 brown paper tickets.
Joe Rogan were,
were at fucking New York at the theater was sold out already.
Fucking Thursday,
Friday night for whatever that five four uh,
what else?
When is that?
How many leases next Thursday.
It's next.
Next week.
Next Thursday.
Wow.
Yeah.
We're in the grand ball.
Your grand ballroom in New York City on Friday,
which should be to know.
What's the address brother?
I do not know.
Can you check it for Yoko?
Joey,
you start that.
It's a,
the,
it's at the Manhattan Center over the hell that is,
it's fine.
It's Manhattan Center and it's on,
uh,
West 34th street.
This is going to be fine.
We,
and we haven't been back to New York and on a least a year.
And then on top of that,
you know,
the coming off that Atlanta trip,
man,
I can't wait to get out to do another show.
That was fun.
It's so relieving,
having filmed the special,
get it out there and you know,
having just done have it an off my back,
right Joey,
woody tweeting.
If I'm not doing nothing,
I swear to God I don't tweet when I'm doing,
I'm not and they'll go,
whoa,
thank all you mother fuckers from making that CD number one.
It's still number two.
Y'all going have to in front of us as a podcast today.
As a matter of fact,
today I got the email officially from billboard,
it's a number one comedy album on Billboard magazine series.
Go check that month and 31 on the Polish,
whatever.
Heatseeker we ain't fucking around but it's thanks to all of these motherfuckers
that gave me a chance.
I tools guy hit me up today and he goes,
can you do me a favor?
You dropped in the state but you're on fire in Canada,
the UK and they want stories so I'm going to start putting stories up there once
a month on iTunes.
Part of my stories.
Things from the Ice House.
$2 a piece down 99 you've been already got prison.
And I got the drug stories I did last night.
You've been number one.
You're number one for weeks,
weeks.
How crazy did that feel?
What was that?
Did it feel like nothing because I didn't expected Joel.
I tell you the truth,
but it felt like something to me.
You call me up.
You are so happy.
What would it fuck it feel like to you that when nobody's giving you a chance
and you're an underdog and you believed in me,
you put me on your podcast.
I did the rest of the fucking work.
And here we are.
You know we want to go on that squad,
but that's not my dream.
I want all of us to start headline.
They,
we were all in a different fucking club.
We're going to shut down the system.
What you did for us,
me,
Ari,
Duncan,
Brian,
uh,
Freddy Loc card,
you know Jason Tebow,
Tam,
Tripoli,
the original debt squad.
What'd you have done for us is give us the same light Rodney gave us and look
what happened and as far as I'm alive,
I'm never going to let you down.
I'm going to,
we're going to the next year motherfuckers what we got coming at you.
You might as well stop listening to everybody else right now I'm telling you
because there's only going to get better.
I give you my word that speaks that Ben Rothwell made was one of the most,
I felt fucking cause that's how I feel.
I had nothing until I got these people on Twitter and Facebook and all I dream
about is to give them funny shit.
Now when I get up at six in the morning,
that's all I want to do.
I don't tweet.
Nonetheless,
it's fucking gold.
Hey,
I'm doing that and I do it for you guys and I think Joe feels the same and red
van,
but this number,
one hour I didn't you Joe.
How long have you known me?
I'm not in.
I don't give a fuck about what people think.
This is overwhelmed me to be a better person.
Not even to be a better comic.
This is teaching me to be a better person because you gave me a chance in life.
When somebody gives you a chance in life,
dog,
it's the best feeling in the world.
I can't dish.
I don't care about the money.
I don't care about CD being number one.
It's just a thing that these people put me there.
Well,
you didn't put myself there,
Joe.
You know I didn't put,
they put me that dog.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you know what you're doing is the right thing.
you're doing is you're,
you're a comic.
You're a real,
like you're out there busting your ass constantly doing shows,
constantly writing,
constantly having fun.
You know,
you're the life of the party man.
Never went to Montreal.
No comedy central special,
no love at Bailey.
Got to manage them and got an agent.
I just show up and so it's all because of you guys because I don't give a fuck.
I've never given a fuck.
And this one.
That's what I love it now you motherfuckers,
now you've got problems.
If you're on my Facebook and put a page and then you come to one of my shows,
I sweat on my mother's grave.
You mother fuckers have created a Frankenstein.
Don't come crying to me when I fucking die on a stage one night.
Dropping knowledge because you must put this,
brought it out of me.
I appreciate Joe Rogan with all my heart.
I mean what you did bro,
for all these Comedians,
not just me,
is what Rodney did.
And with that special,
he changed comedy forever.
Well,
it was for me,
it was just a matter of we,
like I said,
we all enhance each other and it makes me better to be around all you guys.
It's makes me better to be around.
When I listened to you guys go on stage and crush and I know I'm going up later,
it's like,
it makes me feel good.
I'm having fun.
I'm being a part of a fun thing.
And does the experience is a hundred times more fun than just doing it on your
own and you don't want to be the man.
Fuck that.
There's no,
there's no the man.
The man is nonsense.
You want to be a part of a group of brothers,
you know you want to be a part of a brotherhood.
And that Brotherhood extends from the stage into the crowd and that's where it
gets crazy.
You can't tell me that there wasn't some crazy deep connection with the crowd in
Atlanta because of this show.
What they know us about fucking Wisconsin everywhere.
Double Waukee.
Lubo went to Chicago.
How old,
what they used to,
we didn't get out of that Fort Lauderdale.
Where have we got that?
We've gotten somewhere after the show.
We up in Chicago when we looked and there was a line around three fucking
stairways and I wish I was lying county.
There was,
this wasn't one,
it was the same three and it went and I remember looking back there,
I've haven't the only light,
you know what I'm saying?
What's really insane is when you go on stage to that many people and you're
like,
whoa,
this is nuts.
This is a crazy number of fucking human beings.
Joe Rogan I went to,
I went on,
I did these bad flavor worlds and I went on to Twitter to Facebook and I said,
listen,
I want to,
I got $1,400 that I saved up.
Can you guys help me out?
And I got $3,100 sent to me on Twitter and Facebook.
My wife was like,
where were these bitches 10 years ago?
We needed the money.
Now they send you a dirty one.
And I took that 4,500 pounds and I went,
I've got two plane tickets.
I took my friend in New York and we taped this documentary about just where I
grew up,
the people I was around,
I've never done that for nobody.
And now it's been ready since January.
But I want it to be so perfect for these people that we've been making cuts and
adjustments and just just to show them on what,
to see where I came from,
whether they like it or not.
And I'm going to put it up and sell for five bucks like everything else or
everybody who donate is a fucking producer on this thing and they all help this.
Do you think this is all going?
Where are we going,
Joey?
We're going to get an out of network on Youtube because when they come to offer
is something from the network.
What are we going to do on a network?
Take orders.
At this point I'm not taking the real body to do,
would be to start a podcast network,
a real podcast network online and all of us be connected.
All of us be independent but all connected.
That's just the beginning.
I want to connect.
Camera's all over.
Be able to show me.
I want to show people the shit that comes out of my ass.
I want to get everything.
I want to give these people everything,
Bro.
They been there for us.
What don't they give us?
I showed very unusual.
What these fuck.
Don't see these people.
They come to the shows.
They buy posters would take [inaudible] six deep now.
Now what?
They're going to bring in any of the Bj,
can you imagine that shit?
Any problem be Jake gigs like fucking eat.
He wants to MC.
He's going to start MCNC show,
but I just want to thank everybody for finally after 20 years making me a
comedian.
The reason you're appreciated,
that's the reason where you're appreciative is because you're thinking the right
way.
Use motherfucker.
Y'all patient avoid.
They did and you know what?
We're all extremely lucky and we're extremely lucky that we have an audience
like this.
We're extremely lucky that the internet exists.
That US dumb fucks can connect some wires to box.
It's in a fucking cable that's in the ground and somehow or another it gets to
everybody all over the world.
Who the fuck figured that out?
That's amazing.
We're lucky that that exists.
We're lucky we know each other.
We're lucky we're in this crazy business,
a stand comedy.
We're
lucky we could do podcasts and travel and do the UFC and I'm,
I'm lucky.
Most of all for the abundance of cool people that I have in my life.
And thanks to this podcast,
you all get to hang with us.
You get to hang with Joey Diaz,
you get to hang with Freddy Loc car.
You get to sit down and shoot the shit with Brian Cowen and you get to meet the
machine.
Bert Kreischer,
you know,
we're all in this together,
folks.
This is a crazy ride we're all living in and we can enhance each other's
experience on this crazy fucked up rod.
Just enjoy the shit out of it.
Listen to the wonderful world of Joey Diaz by buying his new CD on iTunes.
It's me or the priest.
Is that what it is?
He fucking bulldozers.
Come.
It's me that you are the priest.
See the,
you have the priests.
They already bought it.
I gotta give him props for giving me a chance.
That's it.
So,
um,
uh,
everybody that came to Atlanta,
thank you very much.
It couldn't have been any better.
It was,
it was literally the perfect experience.
I never recorded anything that's any better.
And it comes out as soon as we get around to editing it and we have to set up
the infrastructure to put it out for release.
So it'll be a little bit,
a little bit,
but it's a,
I couldn't have been happier and as because of you guys,
so thank you very much.
And we'll see you next week.
Monday we got ours.
Your fear.
I think we might do Brian Cowen sometime real soon too.
He's trying to figure it out and I got some other people coming up.
Some,
some special guests.
Lots of cool shit.
I've been in touch with the dude from finding bigfoot.
Bobo is going to do the podcast,
the big squatch guy.
Yeah,
that's right.
Bitches.
He claims that there's fucking DNA evidence.
He claims that,
uh,
they've,
apparently there's some fucking DNA from pink foot poop and some different stuff
that they find.
Hope he's right.
It be my dream.
If that show finding big foot actually find you gotta watch that episode of
South Park.
Oh,
is it good as it guys gap.
Well.
All right ladies,
gentlemen.
We love you and we'll see.
We'll see you very soon.
Oh,
the tongue Friday.
ICEHOUSE chronicles.
It will be on this Ustream page,
which is a Ustream.
Dot.
TV Ford Slash Joe Rogan,
uh,
Ustream.
Dot TV.
That what it is.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
the icehouse chronicles,
this Friday night is at Pasadena.
It will sell out.
It's me.
Who else is on it?
I got little Esther,
little Esther,
powerful little SDRs.
Mark Ellis,
and we got off of Mark Ellis Kidd.
Oh Shit.
Max Max.
Does it go?
What's he go by?
Silverstein.
Ah,
yeah.
Nice.
And Tony Hinchcliffe.
Funny fucking kid too.
Nice.
Yeah,
we're going to get dicey.
That kid is dying.
He's dices kid and he's fucking doing well.
He's actually,
he loves standup comedy,
which,
you know,
I was thinking about like what else could he do?
Man?
You're,
you're a kid.
He's a drama.
He's a bad,
well,
you'd have to do something.
I'm saying like you'd have to be in a band or something.
He's going to drop it.
The teacher is like,
I forget what the go video piece that's was drumming for Rod Stewart.
He was the Rod Stewart band.
Oh,
and if you want the Eureka,
go to Ed Ho uh,
organic and bird back in Lancashire visit one that they're going to close those
bitches down.
There's the Da's and that we,
oh,
did you really say that?
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is not the opinions
we need to do
to close down meth labs.
Got nothing to do with us.
We'd be,
ain't got nothing to do with this.
[inaudible] I've got anxiety.
You've got an asshole that hurts and Brian's fucked up from all of God.
That's why we stopped by the [inaudible].
I love you and I love the government.
Stay black is the government did mushrooms.
They'd all be on our side.
It's that simple.
We'd all be together in this fucking thing.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
Maybe I'm just talking shit.
See you soon.
Bye.
Flashlight.
Oh yeah.
Well a couple of sponsors,
Brian,
we have a new one that we're talking about today.
We were talking on the phone and it'll start in June.
It's a video game company.
We were super excited about it cause they got some bad ass video there.
Look,
they really looks amazing.
It's pretty crazy at how awesome the graphics now are on these iPads and it's
really cool that you can maneuver the iPad.
The gyroscope can,
you can make you like drive and move.
Yeah,
we're living in the fucking future.
Direct scope.
That's it.
Is it a euro scope?
That's a sandwich.
Can I eat you dirty fucking freaks.
Thanks to the fleshlight for sponsoring our podcast and if you thinking about
doing one,
didn't that grow from the flashlights?
Say something crazy girl that used to work said something crazy about like we
have like one and 75 people that clicks buys a flush,
clicked it by ratio.
Then like it's shocking how nice.
I said,
yeah,
they said our click to buy ratio is off the chain.
So we appreciate the fuck out of that Lazy Gentlemen.
We really do.
And I knew that that was the perfect sponsor for us.
I mean it really is.
It's,
it's a really solid product,
man.
It's perfect sex toy.
Yeah,
it really works.
What are you doing?
You're doing 30 seconds.
30 seconds.
Okay,
everybody got Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and in the coronary renting you save
yourself 15 to 12 thanks to [inaudible] dot com go to o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom tech sport from tech a and all that good stuff.
Go check it out.
And a first 30 pills,
a hundred percent money back entry.
That's it.
Bye Bye.
[inaudible].